Fox News
lost
to CNN that's right sorry Brian Kilmeade
uh your ratings in the key demo are
lower than that of Anderson Cooper's CNN
they must be screaming and celebrating
and high-fiving each other after this
major blunder Tucker Carlson's out the
ratings for the 8 PM slot on Fox News
have dropped by about 50 percent and in
the key demo they fall into third place
now to be fair they're still winning in
terms of General audience but from 3.3
million viewers down to 1.7 in the key
demo less than CNN wow
talk about embarrassing so uh we'll get
into that story plus we got a bunch of
other political political stuff
happening but we'll just jump to it
before we get started however my friends
head over to
publicsq.com it's Public Square
Public Square is an app that allows you
to find businesses that actually support
American values so right now as we are
all getting with joy that the
Anheuser-Busch boycott is working
swimmingly there's something you can do
you can download the Public Square app
by going to publicescue.com and finding
businesses on the map in your area that
you can support so that you're voting
with your dollars if you're tired of
Corporations and businesses that hate
your guts and you don't like the idea
that you're giving them money this is
how you can find out whether or not your
local businesses actually support you
and your values and not only that many
of these businesses are online
businesses as well so that means if
you're going to order something off the
internet you can go on the app you can
find more businesses we're big fans of
Public Square so special shout out you
can find the link in the description
below download the app sign up today
publicsq.com and also don't forget head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly by clicking
that join us button and you'll get
access to our members only Discord
server where you can hang out
like-minded individuals and you will
also get access to the members only
uncensored show Monday through Thursday
at about 10 10 p.m they go live on the
front page of the website and if you
sign up for at least six months or at
the 25 per month level you can submit
questions and potentially be a caller
coming onto the show and hanging out
with us and asking us questions we do
about four or five every night it's the
most fun I say and so we really do
appreciate your support so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share this show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Steve krakauer hey
man great to be here appreciate it
absolutely who are you what do you do
yeah so I'm a journalist I've had a lot
of different jobs over the last 15 years
or so most recently I just wrote a book
uncovered how the media got cozy with
power abandoned its principles and lost
the people tracks how Corporate media
just completely went off the rails of
the last seven years and uh and you know
really try to interview a bunch of
people not just my opinion but talk to
25 people on the record everyone's on
the record no Anonymous sources
including people like Tucker Carlson
reporters at the New York times in other
places and you can follow my my media
writing on every weekly basis
fourthwatch.media at substack and my day
job I normally I spend my time as the
executive producer of Ben Kelly's show
oh wow well there you go that's a lot of
stuff that's interesting uh considering
the media is collapsing yeah ABC News uh
got is getting rid of Nate silver
BuzzFeed news is gone Don lemon's gone
and Tucker so thanks for hanging out man
it should be fun uh happy to be here
really honored right on we got the
Potato Man himself this is unbelievable
I'm just going to get up and leave at
some point it's going to be Kanye all
over again I thought that was your thing
I thought you liked being called The
Potato Man I I've told you repeatedly
never to address me in such a manner
again and I'm constantly insulted ladies
and gentlemen my name is Sheamus
Coughlin I run a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes where we make animated
cartoons we're going to be releasing one
tomorrow about the Tucker Carlson Saga I
also wrote a podcast on Rumble it's
called shamer if you all want to go
check that out and uh I look in I I'm
just looking forward to the show and to
school and Tim with some facts and logic
about his anti-irish bigotry and having
a great conversation with everybody else
I am Irish and yet you're self-hating
it's a sad thing Adrian Norman's back
what's up guys Adrian Norman here staff
writer at timcast and not Ian Ian's not
here I'm black Ian Black Ian all right
we'll go with that one Adrian it's
almost in there Ian's in there oh my
gosh that's true and then we got search
pressing the buttons what's up guys
search.com uh excited for today be fun
all right let's jump into this first
story from mediaite cable news ratings
Tuesday April 25th Fox News winds 8 P.M
in total viewers but lands third in demo
I love how they kind of bury the lead
you'd think they'd headline this
similarly to what we did check it out
the hour hosted by Brian kilman and Fox
News brought in 1.7 million viewers
which beat Chris Hayes's 1.45 and
Anderson Cooper landed in third with 678
000. what they're not telling you is
that Tucker Carlson just this past week
was averaging 3 0.3 million viewers
meaning Fox News lost nearly half of
Their audience when they got rid of
Carlson and uh okay I think
Tucker is happy I saw a video of him
riding around at a golf course a golf
cart with his wife laughing so he's
probably like great I can start my own
company make a ton of money
here's what gets interesting though if
we jump down to the key demo viewership
take a look at this if we go to the 8 PM
Fox News Tonight 149
000 viewers in the key demo Anderson
Cooper and MSNBC both beat Fox News that
is just laughably embarrassing I mean
look at this Jesse Waters beats both CNN
and MSNBC and then at 8 pm CNN and MSNBC
beat Fox News Chris Hayes
has beaten Fox News
embarrassing Chris Hayes and Anderson
Cooper I mean this is this is honestly a
disaster we should point out a demo you
know the a25 25 to 54 year olds that's
what the ad sales are are based on it's
not total viewers is great obviously you
want a big number of total viewers but
in terms of the the traditional Legacy
Media that these these cable networks
are all that matters is the demo number
and that demo number last week Tucker
Carlson was I mean 400 500 000 I mean
that's as typical 160
000 that is insane and if not 149 149
and it's not just even the 8 PM hour
it's dragging down 9 PM with Sean
Hannity and 10 p.m it's it's a massive
massive problem so I got a question for
you though I don't know if you have the
experience in here if I were to have
bought an ad on Fox News and I was like
we want to run Monday at 8pm and they
went you got it and then they removed
Tucker I get my money back right that's
a good question if you bought it
specifically for Tucker yeah do you now
get it that's a good question in fact
now that it's not called Tucker Carlson
tonight that may be your way of getting
it back because now oh now it's Fox News
tonight or whatever they're calling it
in the interim uh yeah no look this is
this is a disaster I mean obviously
Tucker leaving is one thing Tucker is
going to be fine I mean we we've been
kind of I mean everyone in the media is
over text and direct message it's like
the talk of what does Tucker Carlson do
next he will eventually do something
next he's obviously under contract right
now he can't even talk but he will
eventually do something next but what
happens with Fox this is not the same as
what happened I would say when Bill
O'Reilly left or when other top Stars
left Tucker Carlson is a singular voice
and an incredibly important voice in
this particular moment and and they lose
that and that is going to have a massive
preparations I just want to make sure we
don't leave out our good friend Cuomo
who scored 26 000 viewers in the key
demo holy crap and then um Cuomo 11 p.m
get this eight eight thousand in the
demo yeah eight eight thousand holy crap
he probably made a whole 20 bucks off
that show that's that's okay dude if I
made a YouTube video that only got 8 000
views I think it would make like 20
dollars that's that's not stunning in in
total to be fair in total viewership
Cuomo got 156 000 and then Cuomo at 11
PM got 80 000.
oh how the mighty have fallen Cuomo I
guess whatever but I think I think
Tucker Carlson's probably gonna you know
he's gonna launch his own network or
something you were saying that there was
like some kind of rumor about why he got
fired because like he was he was hitting
on well not really but no yeah hold on
this is how rumors get started man
this is not what he said what did he say
uh that Rupert Murdoch's go actually
this is Gossip I couldn't even tell you
but basically I'll let you tell the
story it has been reported in fact it
was reported even before Monday when
this all you know hit the fan and
Tucker was gone that Rupert he had
dinner with Rupert Murdoch and Rupert is
now now ex-fiance who apparently at the
reporting is you know from weeks ago
again this is not related to Tucker
getting fired the reporting is that the
fiance was like obsessed with Tucker
Carlson he called him like this gift
from God and as we the only reason
Tucker Carlson is no longer on the air
at Fox is because Rupert Murdoch soured
on him for one reason or another who
knows exactly what that reason is but
was that part of the tension in the
relationship was the experience of
Tucker himself and whether he's the gift
from God or not I don't know the Chad
Tucker Carlson and the like soy Jack
Rupert Murdoch you should be a million
different memes of this yeah so he
decided to get rid of him I guess I
wonder if it's also because it's not so
much about the relationship I mean the
dude's like 92 years old but maybe that
him hearing her say this he's like this
man is becoming bigger than my own
company yeah you know what I mean he's
like Fox News is me not Tucker no we're
getting rid of him and so but that's
such a bad solution right instead of
continuing to make money off of him I'll
just let him go make money without me it
should have been essentially let your
ego kind of destroy the company I mean
those are big shoes to feel who's going
to step in and be able to fill that time
slot and be able to bring the presence
and the gravitas that Tucker brings
nobody you know I think that they're
going to try to Brian kill me run oh
yeah absolutely he's clearly he's
knocking out of the park give him some
time I mean I I feel bad for anyone who
gets put in that time slot we were
talking about this before the show well
it's no fault for taking it yeah dude if
if I was like if I was contracted at Fox
News Hannity or Ingram or anybody and
they were like you're doing 8pm but like
hell no I'm not are you crazy I know
yeah yeah everybody's ragging on Brian
Kilby nobody cared about kill me before
this but now that he took Tucker
Tucker's time slot everybody's making
fun of him yeah it's just like dude you
get dead air you get nothing at 8pm
because nobody wants to take that spot
because if if Tucker was like I'm
leaving the network people would be sad
but the fact that they unceremoniously
removed him them and it may be because
Murdoch was jealous now it's Mega cringe
to try and take his time slot well I
sort of Wonder too if they're gonna try
to replace him with with some kind of
bad boy-esque figures since Tucker was
the anti-establishment guy but someone
who's still brand safe and doesn't push
fox in a direction that they're
uncomfortable no they possibly have they
could do that I don't know some some
young upstart that they find guys if you
want to find me you know I can no I'm
totally kidding I would never I would
never be allowed on Fox the whole
executive office at foxes are busting
out laughing I busted out laughing
cannot hire me I don't apply
but I I really do wonder what they're
gonna try to do because obviously this
guy's gonna have to get taken out of the
the spot he's not going to perform well
but I wonder if there's another element
that people are saying they're getting
they're removing him right before the
election kicks off right Trump's running
DeSantis is probably gonna start running
they just changed that law in Florida I
think what is it the the rain to run or
whatever it's called yeah where you have
to resign they got rid of that didn't
they yeah
um yeah yeah so yeah it seems like
DeSantis is going to run and Tucker is a
powerful voice propping up candidates
like Trump or DeSantis now he is not
there right right yeah Tucker is look I
mean I've interviewed Tucker Carlson for
about seven or eight times over the
course of the last 15 years I've known
him since 2008. he is you know in in my
book uncovered he talks to me about the
fact that he was Hunter Biden's neighbor
I mean this is a guy who was in The
Establishment in that way uh was was on
the first chapter of the book is about
Hunter Biden's laptop Tucker tells me I
knew it was real from the minute I saw
it because I have emails with me and
Hunter Biden
he was in the laptop he was in that
world he was in the laptop yes in the
world in the laptop you know a guy who
who knew the Biden family I mean he
tells me in the book that he knew Biden
has dementia because he's heard from
Biden's family that he had to mention
this was before he ran so this is a guy
who was in that world and then became
the turncoat in a lot of the same ways
that Trump did in the New York media
scene and so you're not going to be able
to find that you're not going to be able
to get the guy who knew what was going
on in DC who knows all the same people
and can expose that the left and the
right I mean he goes after the right
harder than anyone else on Fox and if
you're looking for a reason why you want
a guy like that to not be on the air for
the next year which is like the length
of his contract there there's your
reason I mean he he is someone who's a
total differentiator from The
Establishment voice that's on the right
or or anywhere else and he's a threat to
the entire establishment Left End right
he's done it in the segments on kovid on
military policy on the expansion of
government throughout the years I mean
he's a guy that can sort of bring down
the entire house just like Donald Trump
right yeah a lot about China too that
the media generally doesn't want to go
near
yeah I mean look in the Dominion tax
that came out which were embarrassing
for sure for for Fox I mean obviously
they settled the Dominion lawsuit the
texts come out he's really rough on
Trump I mean he's calling him like this
evil guy essentially anyways this was
the post-election period and and these
all come out you would think oh that
should be embarrassing and then two
weeks ago he's sitting down with Trump
for an hour-long interview in Mar-A-Lago
and and praising him in some ways and
pushing him in other ways but this is a
guy who can do can do both those things
he can be critical he can be he has The
credibility trump it will go I mean he
was just interviewed about it what do
you think about Tucker losing his job
he's sitting there praising him this is
a guy who's calling him essentially evil
in these text messages that are coming
out in the wake of the 2020 election so
you lose something massive by not having
a voice like that a guy who can it
really cannot be replaced I mean the the
Legacy Media industry is every single
day even if they were doing everything
right less and less people are watching
traditional tv less and less people are
are finding that so when you're not
going going to maximize the time you
have left by getting someone who is a
star a Bonafide star and you take them
off the air you you're you're really
just you're it's the end of it ladies
and gentlemen just a few moments ago
around the start of this show Tucker
Carlson posted a video on Twitter that
says good evening I have no idea what
he's going to say so I hope we don't get
banned here's what he said you think
it's Tucker Carlson one of the first
things you realize when you step outside
the noise for a few days is how many
genuinely nice people there are in this
country kind and decent people people
who really care about what's true and a
bunch of hilarious people also a lot of
those it's got to be the majority of the
population even now so that's heartening
the other thing you notice when you take
a little time off is how unbelievably
stupid most of the debates you see on
television are they're completely
irrelevant they mean nothing in five
years we won't even remember that we had
them
trust me as someone who's participated
and yet at the same time and this is the
amazing thing the undeniably big topics
the ones that will Define our future get
virtually no discussion at all war civil
liberties emerging science demographic
change corporate power natural resources
when was the last time you heard a
legitimate debate about any of those
issues it's been a long time debates
like that are not permitted in American
Media both political parties and their
donors have reached consensus on what
benefits them and they actively collude
to shut down any conversation about it
suddenly the United States looks very
much like a one-party state
that's a depressing realization but it's
not permanent our current orthodoxies
won't last they're brain dead nobody
actually believes them hardly anyone's
life is improved by them this moment is
to inherently ridiculous to continue and
so it won't
the people in charge know this that's
why they're hysterical and aggressive
they're afraid they've given up
persuasion they're resorting to force
but it won't work when honest people say
what's true calmly and without
embarrassment they become powerful at
the same time the Liars who've been
trying to silence them shrink and they
become weaker that's the iron law of the
universe true things prevail
where can you still find Americans
saying true things there aren't many
places left but there are some and
that's enough
as long as you can hear the words there
is hope
see you soon
and he was talking about us that was all
about Jim Kessler yeah where can you
find the truth it's right here
[Laughter]
that's his Studio I'm pretty sure I
think it's in Maine or something like
that so uh that was awesome
um to hear from him he's right about all
of that it's really amazing to see that
he's become this like populist
you know there's that Viral meme we
played last night where it shows him in
the political compass for authoritarian
right and he's like the more they have
you talking about race the less the less
time spent is spent asking about class
why rich people that doesn't like
shifting to the left starts playing this
communist Anthem yeah so I don't know
what do you guys think man uh it was
fairly vague I know that he can't say a
whole lot because he's he's going
through that contract stuff
I mean I think it's pretty uh it's
pretty on brand for how he's been for
the last God knows how many years I mean
it's just it's classic Tucker
um without the the high-pitched laughter
but I mean I think it's it's it's again
maybe he's just sort of trying to flex a
little bit and show that he's going to
be fine and be able to to operate on his
own yeah without having to to go to a
network I mean who's going to write what
do you think it's Tucker Carlson started
automatically playing again like who's
gonna write him a check who can afford
to Pam I mean it's just boring It Off
from 500 million dollars to come over
the daily wire like his best move is to
sort of do his thing and I think we'll
probably see more content coming out
just independently from him because he's
able to do it and like you said earlier
he built Daily Caller yeah and he's
perfectly capable of building another
Network and and being his own man and
not having to be a slave to any anybody
affiliate with your staff does he still
own the Daily Caller he sold out
recently yeah pretty recently no I mean
but first of all this is just like the
quintessential Tucker Carlson right it's
8 P.M when his show starts when Brian
Kilmeade is filling in for him
he's already got almost more viewers
than kill Mead he's got 107 000 views in
this one video he just posted I mean
that's the thing about the internet
versus TV anyway you get more views on a
snippet little video he could put up a
video on Tick Tock and get more views
yeah absolutely Tucker and that's what I
think his next move is he's gonna start
doing Tick Tock dances and stuff all
right so it's about yeah yeah that's
that's what we've we've all wanted to
see is is hope for yeah he's already got
242 400 views oh my God on this video
and uh I'm assuming it's Twitter so it's
mostly key demo right and Brian kill me
it only got 149. I feel bad for kill me
man I got no beef you know but like what
are you doing but this is also like the
shift right you mean yes traditional
ratings there's not exactly Apples to
Apples with with views on YouTube or
Twitter or whatever but that that is a
very very small number I mean not wasn't
that long ago that that three million
number at Fox was 5 million uh yeah
we're talking about five years ago I
mean it was just the the way the
audience is Shifting is is happening but
but yeah look Tucker started Daily
Caller in between his time in
Mississippi MSNBC which is you know kind
of funny to think he was a host on MSNBC
he gave Rachel Maddow or start I mean
this is a guy who has had a very
fascinating career starts Daily Caller I
interviewed him in 2010 he had bought
Keith olbermann.com he found out that
Keith urbanman.com was was available for
sale and so he buys it he gets the email
address Keith at Keith olberman.com and
just to to with Keith he like he he
starts emailing people as if he's Keith
olberman to start scaring people I
interviewed him about it and he's just
talking about how he's the most hated
man in the building and this is Keith
still at MSNBC so he just uses it he's
funny he's smart he's different and look
I mean apparently now he's he's free to
at least drop some videos every now and
then did you hear this thing about this
woman accusing of sexism yeah she was
his old Booker said that he he like he
and others destroyed her we have the
story from the post millennial I saw
this on Twitter ex-producer suing Tucker
Carlson has never even met him what the
how do they hire these people yeah like
does Fox have like a vetting process
where they're just like right this way
sir and walk through the door and that's
it they're like do you agree with us we
don't know okay well come on in this
person has apparently according to her
interview with MSNBC yesterday has 90
tapes I mean it has spent her entire
career apparently at Fox just recording
people ready to drop this uh yes never
met Tucker Carlson really has no real
beef with Tucker personally as as trying
to make it about Tucker's staff and the
culture that he's started there I think
she you know potentially has him on tape
saying something things that are you
know sexist or whatever she wants to to
try to portray there uh she also buy it
no no no did you see those uh they're
saying they got secret recordings of Ted
Cruz oh yeah I think from her saying
yeah and and Ted Cruz he's he's saying
something yeah probably he's talking to
Maria Bartiromo and he's like he says
something to the effect of if there's
gonna be some kind of challenge to the
election then you've got to have an
actually an actual sanctioned commission
that reviews the evidence and then if
the evidence is there you present it
that's what he says and the left is like
he's trying to overthrow the election
it's like it sounds like Ted Cruz is
trying to stop them from doing it being
like no no no you got to go through the
formal formal process and get a a
commission set up before you can do any
of this and they're they're using Ted
Cruz resisting the stuff as evidence he
was in favor of it yeah honestly you
just to stick with Tucker for a second
the person who was the strongest against
the election fraud stuff on the air at
Fox I was talking Carlson right he he
did a 15-minute monologue that was
really powerful that just completely
obliterated Sydney Powell why won't
Sydney Powell come on my show and talk
about this I'll give her the whole night
I'll give her the whole week she won't
come on we've asked for evidence she
won't show it we're telling you this
because it's true I mean that's the kind
of person he was and and separate from
that just the entire we're still seeing
this now it's three years later
everything that can be part of the what
I would call the Trump Addiction in the
corporate media which I I think all of
this election stuff is they're going to
try to make the story of Ted Cruz's
comment that's like the most Ted Cruz
thing possible I mean it's just like
this lawyer who's talking about oh well
you know like you've got to have a
Commissioners yes insurrectionist yes
he's literally describing a process like
he wants to take over the government
okay he's demanding hard evidence and a
formal hearing to over to look at the
evidence yeah and their immediate
response is it was his a coup attempt
yep right but this is why people don't
trust the the corporate media I mean
it's it's honestly I I write about this
a lot in uncovered it's like there's
there starts with the seed of something
whether it's you know the steel dossier
Russia gate the media covers something
in a specific way I call it glance
journalism like you get it at the glance
an initial story and then they just move
on to the next thing and and they never
go back and start to correct it they're
they're so addicted to to Trump and to
anything that's kind of the ancillary
the January 6th or the election process
so addicted to it and the average
American left right or Center is not in
that same mindset I mean they are not
just completely addicted in the way that
these media people are I I've talked to
people that uh could not sleep that had
to take pills because they were just
just so overcome with with this feeling
that they're in this existential fight
with Donald Trump during the Trump
residency and and it made them
completely put the guardrails of
Journalism out when they tried to to try
to take him down and it was so obvious
to the audience and to this day I mean
they have not learned a single lesson no
I think they were driven insane yeah and
I don't think it was Trump I think it
was social media algorithms because
there's there's no real reason to be so
mad at Trump yeah like any reasonable
person who's like man like if you were
looking at Trump and you genuinely
didn't like him because you liked didn't
like his policies or his attitude you
wouldn't be screaming that he was Hitler
you just be like I don't like this guy
yeah they got driven to the extreme end
because the internet was screaming as
loud as possible in their faces exactly
so for example with somebody like Joe
Biden I mean I had to test absolutely
everything the man stands for I don't
have to take sleeping pills because the
president it's insane to have such a
small Petty outlook on life my goal is
to go after this person and take them
down for some bizarre reason they saw
him as the embodiment of every principle
that they hated despite the fact that he
was basically a New York Democrat in
many ways at least with respect to his
Economic Policy decision making he was
more socially conservative being there
he was like somewhere between center
right and Centrist this was not some
far-right political leader and even if
he was to be even if he was you know on
the actual right by American Standards
or far right or however they would have
defined it
to not be able to sleep over the guy
your audience let's talk about well
let's talk about some presidential
prospects from the post Malone we have
the story Greg Gutfeld jokes Tucker
Carlson Carlson will run for president
after leaving Fox News granted he's
joking he said in 2024 what would be
Susan Rice versus Tucker Carlson and uh
then you can see that uh post
Millennials got some some what is that
CSS code or something that's just I'm
going to highlight that so that Libby's
season goes crap Libby what are you
doing
the godfeld host made the comments while
appearing on Fox News The Five alongside
other Fox personalities the panelists
then brought up Democrat Susan Rice
President Biden's White House domestic
policy advisor who announced she would
be departing from her post on Monday
which had the Fox News personalities
predicting she would be a contender in
the 2024 election so he's kind of joking
but kinda not and I'm wondering now
somebody so the conversation is is Trump
Carlson 2024 but then there was a
question I don't know if it was you were
asking it Adrian DeSantis Carlson maybe
that'd be a ticket now here's the thing
if the Republican primary is between
DeSantis Carlson and Trump I'm a happy
man right if these are the kinds of
candidates we're getting because look at
what it was back in 2016. right Trump
was the only person who had politics
besides I guess Ron Paul we almost had
sorry we were very very close to fixing
the system and getting everything done
right yeah exactly Jeff I mean you knew
where I was going all we have had for
for years and years decades or these
boring establishment candidates who just
want to go along with whatever we've got
that name of Jeb with the entire map
turning yellow I don't disagree that it
we should have picked Jeff but we missed
our opportunity but it's be real to be
real Jeb is The One That Got Away
there's no getting Jeb back he's gone
he's out of our life I thought where you
were going with that was being serious
about it because honestly we almost got
Trump versus Bernie in 2010 oh right and
and yes I mean I I like it's it's still
amazing to me that we didn't get burned
burning was well like the front runner
Bernie was leading the charge against
the Democrat establishment and then got
to the DNC stopped turned around and
said you are all trespassing and you
must leave
so it was like he let everyone there and
then just immediately joined with
Hillary and then he was like if you want
to be a millionaire you write a book
well yeah but that's 2016. yeah in 2020
he was I mean they went to Nevada and I
read about this uncovered MSNBC Joy Reid
people like that went after Bernie
Sanders when at Chris Matthews when he
was still back on the air before he got
me too they they went completely all in
on Joe Biden because they needed to stop
him in the same way that mayor peed and
Amy Klobuchar drop dropped out yeah and
endorsed by right before super Tuesday I
mean these people were contenders I mean
not huge contenders but they they all
galvanized in the same way the politics
did the the music did this is the best
thing this is the best thing here here
this my friends so boo to judge drops
out of the race endorses Joe Biden why
it's obvious they were siphoning away
votes they were breaking the the
moderate vote and Bernie was then taking
the lead if Klobuchar Buddha judge if
they drop out and endorse Biden Biden
gets a big bump beats Bernie Sanders
likely would have happens is that Joe
Biden goes to them and says I will make
you a deal
Pete you drop out we got a job for you
he says okay you got it how about
something cushy a do-nothing job like
Transportation secretary you don't have
to pay attention
and Pete's like so you're saying I don't
have to do any work it's like what's the
job you look at a screen and some trucks
driving by you and got to do anything
nobody pays attention when's the last
time you saw a transportation secretary
on TV
and now look where we are yeah but for
real that's probably what happened oh
yeah so he drops out they're like it's
the job is yours and then a train blows
up and he's like not there well I
thought this supposed to be an easy job
what's going on I also think this is not
um necessarily in original Insight other
people have said this this is something
Dave Smith has said before too but there
is something to be said about the fact
that the way Bernie treated the people
he was running against didn't really
match his rhetoric about the fact that
they were screwing the working class
right Trump's treatment of other
political leaders matches his rhetoric
on how he feels about political leaders
he's not nice to them and then Bernie
Sanders gets on stage he's like oh well
of course I love these people they are
my best friends and it's like okay well
you're not exactly selling to people
that you genuinely want to fight them
but also what did Bernie do he endorsed
Hillary and then he endorsed Joe Biden
so they knew they could take it from him
Donald Trump wasn't going to endorse any
other Republican if he didn't get that
right I know so they knew they had to
give it to him the way I like to
describe it is this big Ivory Tower and
Bernie comes from the left up the hill
with a bunch of angry you know leftists
and then Trump comes up on the right
with a bunch of angry angry right
Wingers and then they're both standing
on each side and the elites are looking
down like oh what do we do what do we do
and then Bernie is like I am humbly
asking that you open the door and then
they're like okay and then knock knock
and then Bernie's like I'm gonna go
inside real quick and uh and work
something out with them and then next
thing you know Bernie's sticking South
the window being like get out of here
get out but then Trump kicks the door in
and just starts rampaging through the
Halls like a bull that's an Insurrection
and they're freaking out they're like
it's interaction
and then Tucker Carlson releases the
security camera footage what happened
after they broke down the door of the
castle and then Bernie's running away
with them yeah it's like like the the
Bernie becoming a millionaire is the
perfect example of what's wrong with
Bernie Sanders yes when when he has what
four houses three three houses yeah what
was his recent book his book was like
why it's wrong to be a millionaire or
something like that you know it's like
he stopped saying millionaires when he
became one right yeah the Millionaires
and the billionaires then he became a
millionaire and he stopped saying it and
I'm like Bernie you don't have to stop
saying it because you're rich there are
people of 999 million dollars you can
make that point but he's a he's a
grifter yeah so that was it that talk
about a letdown well he said look when
you write a best-selling book you could
be a millionaire too as if the
publishing industry doesn't follow the
same mechanisms that socialists
criticizing other Industries like well
what about the logger who cut down the
trees that was that were then turned
into the paper Bernie and what about the
people operating the printing press like
why don't they all get an equal share in
the Prof of your book The World
socialist website called Bernie Sanders
a nationalist capitalist
no joke what is it the world socialist
website called Bernie Sanders a
nationalist capitalist wow because he's
in favor of capital capitalist
structures even though he's Fair he's
far left he still is talking about
Capital structures and he wants to
secure the borders so that he can
protect workers he had a quote at a
rally where he said we can't have open
borders my God the people they would all
just flood in and then they were like
how dare you you nationalist capitalists
didn't he call it a Koch brother scheme
yeah in 28 2015. yeah he's had been born
as a Koch brothers proposal to get cheap
labor I mean it's it's amazing to me how
Democrats
claim they're in favor of unions they
know that a scab entering into a
workplace when they're not a member of a
union could drive wages down but when
you place that or abstract that onto a
national scale they're unwilling to
recognize that that's true wait a minute
what about like the literal Union that
we call like the United States of
America don't you think someone entering
into our Union who isn't playing by the
same rules and isn't becoming a
registered member taking jobs might
lower average wages for the people who
are already in the country but for
whatever reason the principal stops
operating there yeah that's why
immigration honestly was the biggest
issue you know cross party for Donald
Trump I think but honestly like I hate
to go back to Tucker again but another
thing he said it's like even Trump gets
in there and yes he was totally
anti-establishment anti-elite that's
what got him in but Tucker told me for
the book that you know he gets in there
and he puts Steve mnuchin in treasury or
or a lot of the people that he put in
these positions a lot of the things that
he said and this is some of the things
that Tucker has been critical of trump
about more recently is when he actually
got in there you still you okay you
drain the swamp all that and yes he was
he said the right things but ultimately
how did he govern there's still some
criticism there and actually I think
like a candidate who really wants to go
after Trump for from the right like a
DeSantis I don't know if he's got it in
him would be to say well you got in
there kovid whatever else you know
border did you actually do what you said
you were going to do and and break up
the the actual you know Elite
establishment that you that you claim to
be doing somewhat but only a little bit
yeah not enough right not enough but uh
enough to where I'm looking forward to
Trump getting revenge schedule F yeah
and and I think what really makes this
work is if Trump just had his term and
then lost and there was no Russia gate
and there was no impeachment and all
that stuff
I wouldn't know if I'd be so enthused
I'd be like well you know we had Trump
like maybe DeSantis is going to work out
I don't know but the fact that they've
they've gone after Trump so heavy
heavy-handedly handedly the fact that
they're trying to indict him in three
different jurisdictions I'm like okay so
now we're gonna get that equal and
opposite reaction that I'm excited about
they they came at trump super hard and
he's ready to come back schedule a left
lock down take it I love it yeah yeah
I'm ready for it I mean the 100 Biden
laptop story just like the icing on the
cake of the Trump uh you know presidency
I mean the way that the media you know
in collusion with tech companies
inclusion with the FBI as we now know
thanks to the Twitter files lock down
that story and the fact that it has
become so obvious that it was true I
mean it was obviously it was true when
it actually was being written but the
way the media covered it and then what
we now know has just made that just so
clear to everyone that if if that moved
a few thousand votes a couple you know
30 000 votes that would have made
enormous difference in the election and
the fact that they did that that will
stick with people I think and that you
know it's it's a media story but it's a
politic story
yeah uh there there was a poll done on
that as well a very large percentage of
Biden voters had absolutely no idea
about the the hunter Biden story and
about 10 of people who voted for bidenu
reserve it said if they had known about
the hunter Biden laptop story they would
not have voted for Joe yeah I think it
was like 16 but that was enough to have
swung the election depending on where
those orders were but let's let's talk
about the latest Revelation so this is
uh this is huge news there's a letter
released by Jim Jordan showing that uh
what's his name Michael Morrell is that
his name former CIA director outright
said that he he told people the hunter
Biden laptop was this information
because he wanted to help Joe Biden win
right right at the direction of Tony
blinken who's now the Secretary of State
and I think he talked to Biden too
didn't he yeah I I think you know Biden
was involved but it was through the
intermediary who who only of course you
know talk about people like mayor Pete
getting promoted Tony blanket of course
now in a very Prime position there as
Secretary of State and this story does
not get covered very very much in the in
the corporate media these days I mean
this this came out in a house Judiciary
panel Mike Morrell not a partisan guy at
all but just is asked to tell what
happened here well no he is I mean he
said he wanted Biden to win Mike well
yes but but not you know he he was doing
the bidding of of Tony blinken a a
trustworthy person let's just say that I
mean this is not someone who's like you
know trying to to right I mean to your
point a guy from the left is essentially
admitting to what he was doing uh yeah
the that story I mean again a companion
to the hunter Biden lack of coverage
Hunter by laptop lack of coverage was
that story which would you know the way
that yes cnns of the world and I've I've
talked to a lot of people at CNN about
this okay you didn't say it was Russian
disinformation but you put that letter
out there with people that it was 50 all
the former agents of Russian right and
those people who you pay in many
instances people like Clapper and
Brennan are getting paychecks from MSNBC
and CNN they're the ones who are telling
you about looks like Russian
disinformation to us you know we're the
experts you know experts again take a
look at this we got the stir from The
Examiner it says Morrell who testified
to Congress earlier this month about the
laptop letter said he thought now
Secretary of State Anthony blinken
wanted the baseless claims of Russian
involvement in the sagon made public the
former Obama acting CIA director told
house investigators that before was
October 17th call with blinken he had no
intention to write the October 19th
Hunter Biden laptop letter and testified
yes and absolutely when asked if the
call with blinken who was the top
advisor for Biden's 2020 campaign was uh
what was what triggered that intent in
you
Morel also said in a recent transcribed
interview with Congressional
investigators that it was his guest that
blinken called him to talk about the
hunter Biden laptop because the future
Secretary of State wanted it out in the
public that the Russians Were Somehow
involved in the Saga he also testified
that one of the two reasons he helped
put the letter together was to help now
President Joe Biden quote because I
wanted him to win the election
hey how about that what a what a what a
what a time to be alive huh insane and
no punishment for blatant election
interference but you know a question
that I have is these guys weaponize this
entire process to win the 2020 election
right you got a bunch of former Intel
guys partnered with social media
engaging in this in this clear
manipulation of multiple systems just to
get their guy in they were able to even
if you don't want to discuss the the
issue of election fraud they were able
to weaponize this system enough to be
able to prevent Trump from getting
reelected when he wielded the full power
of the executive branch of the United
States government what is what has
changed and let me add one other uh
point in here too we have numerous
States like Pennsylvania that change
election laws in the run-up to the
election to give Democrats an advantage
and prevent Trump from getting in none
of this Republicans were involved in
that right so what has changed since
2020 that they would this deep State
apparatus would allow him back in now
when they've already weaponized the
system preventing to prevent him from
getting in 20
I I don't know if I don't know if I
would phrase it as prevent him I think
what they're trying to do is slant
things as heavily as possible in their
favor and that I think is the game and I
think Republicans need to pay attention
to that they spent too long coming out
screaming fraud fraud fraud instead of
screaming how are they getting these
ballots how are they doing it and then
just doing the same thing ballot chasing
harvesting now Trump is coming out and
being like we're going to do the same
thing now you're hearing Republicans
come out say okay we figured it out
we're going to play the game they're
playing now I think these advantages may
be lost because if Republicans actually
start playing the same game it's going
to slowly bounce out though Universal
mail-in voting greatly advantages
Democrats in dense populated areas and
it's very hard for people in rural areas
to get the word out and things like that
but I think I think Republicans can now
understanding what happened in the past
two elections start utilizing that
properly so we'll see I'm I'm not I
don't want to be black filled on this
one well I I think you're right I mean
the last two elections because that
clearly was a factor in 2022 also in the
midterm absolutely that the fact that
they hadn't made those adjustments at
that point was it was a clear thing but
I honestly think you know going back to
something you said earlier about the
social media incentives uh
what what was the the real story about
this I mean why did so many in the media
not cover this when I went back and
started looking for the book about why
was the Press covered that you know why
do they cover it this way they there
were people like Maggie Haberman at the
New York Times who linked to the New
York Post just said oh I questioned the
sourcing of it I don't know this seems a
little shady and she got trending on
Twitter as Maga Haberman because she
linked to the New York Post even because
she was she was and so Jake Sherman
who's now at punch bowl he was at
Politico at the time
yeah he tweets it also I wonder if the
Biden campaign will respond to this he
gets pilloried by people is forced to
delete it and apologizes for daring to
link to the New York Post so there's
such a a guilt called happens yeah and
and and there's no backbone by a lot of
these journalists and if they get a
bunch of people yelling at them on
Twitter they're gonna just do what the
mob says and so so that's not changing
either that's only getting worse I think
in this new era yeah I think I think
Republicans are starting to wake up and
and just some people have talked to sort
of behind the scenes there's this
realization that yeah we got we have to
do more than we've done in the past to
win elections we got to do the ballot
harvesting but in general we we have to
sort of build out just a bigger ground
game because Democrats have a billion
dollar machine that's been in place for
decades Republicans don't have that
Republicans have a system where the
donor class sort of gives money to the
RNC who does it out how they see fit
where on the Democrat side they have all
these organizations that have been built
out of the grass level these billionaire
donors give to those organizations and
you know the party is a little bit
further down the list so there's a whole
machine apparatus that that needs to be
built on the right but it seems like
people are more inclined to actually do
the work right now and want to build
those things out Scott Pressler is a guy
who's running across the country right
now trying to register voters trying to
uh spread the word about ballot
harvesting and do what he can to build
those systems out and I think it is as
far as what I'm seeing even just this
week Charlie Kirk posted about this
there's more of a focus now on doing the
work that's needed to build out those
systems to try to give Trump the best
chance or whoever is the nominee most
likely Trump but whatever Republican is
the best chance to uh to win the
election next year but here's the plan
we need to use their platform against
them that the strategies they have
they've used against us work needs
against them so when they say vote blue
no matter who here's the pitch Donald
Trump runs as a Democrat we all then
vote for him in the primary and now they
have to vote for it they literally have
no choice Checkmate Democrats it's
beautiful that's right it's going to be
like I'm sorry vote blue no matter who
and they're like put Donald Trump those
are your rules and then they're gonna
have to press the button for Trump oh
and that's how he wins but it is funny
that they say vote blue no matter who
because it clearly shows that you could
put literally anything in the office
they don't care as long as they're
hurting you that's crazy when was the
last time fetterman was seen recently
I mean it was kind of sad yeah I mean
really really sad I tried to read a
statement legitimately yeah he's talking
really weird he's struggling to form
words he can't he can he he clearly
can't understand the responses he's
getting and then he just ignores them
right he'll like ask a question he'll be
like can you
explain
to me why and
if Biden is President and then they say
something and he goes
now have you seen and it's like well did
you are you gonna answer the first thing
they said like he just Boop just didn't
happen I guess yeah and that's with
someone literally running around next to
him with a screen in front of him that
it has the words you know the closed
captioning happening and still is not
really comprehending no but that I'll
take whatever they can get as long as
not a republican yeah well I mean you
got Biden now too right of running again
and it's like really are we doing this I
mean it's hilarious
I don't think I don't think Biden can
win I don't know I I I I will I will be
laughing come 2024 when I find out I'm
wrong or whatever but Biden had the
covid lockdown Advantage he didn't do
anything or go anywhere now they're
saying there's going to be no debates
have you guys heard this yeah no debates
at all none on either side on either
side it's none
I just this is crazy but whatever I
guess Trump's gonna try to get out of
him but I mean there's got to be RNC
debates you know he he obviously is a
former president but he's not the
incumbent so they've got to do RNC
debates and whether he's there or not
DNC I could if you really are have a
feel that's Joe Biden Robert F Kennedy
Jr and Marion Williamson I could see
them really just saying yeah you know
you're on your own you know it's going
to be used to be Biden here although
again I I don't know how you galvanized
behind a person that you I got it yeah
here's what we'll do we will host the
Democratic debates
here Tim guest IRL right here but what
likely will happen is Biden won't come
but guess what I am willing to bet uh uh
RFK Jr will yeah and uh so would Miriam
Williamson for sure yeah and and if if
we're like look we'll do a legit we'll
get a forum we'll get a we'll rent a
building we'll get a you know an actual
theater we'll have anyone who wants to
run and the interesting thing is these
are prominent figures RFK Junior and
Mary Williamson but I wonder if any
other establishment Democrat who wants
to run would actually come yeah right is
it isn't uh who else is running what's
his what's his face
anyone else
um have you interviewed RFK yeah uh uh
yes here we go uh hey uh Hutchinson on
the he's a GOP GPU oh it's GOP Acer oh
whoops I'm an idiot no he's I mean he's
okay he's running around he's
establishment enough that he's right I
know I was just like he's he's one of
those guys isn't he he's a pretty never
Trump so uh you know you see how I got
confused yes if you spend all your days
in like cable news green rooms then
you're basically a Democrat at this
point right which is what he said so is
it just RFK Junior then Megan Williams I
think so far oh that's fantastic yeah we
uh we I'm pretty sure we've reached out
to RFK Juniors team and he'd be a
greater I mean he's a fascinating guy
super smart
um you know we've at the Megyn Kelly
show we've interviewed him a couple
times
um and you know how to had to keep an
eye out to make sure we could keep it
all uh not live on YouTube and all
platforms we will we will do the
Democratic debates live on Rumble with
Marion Williamson and RFK Jr and if Joe
Joe Biden will be invited right we'll
say hey man just let her know let us
know what you need you're invited
absolutely well if anything you anything
you need to make this debate happen and
then when he says no he just won't be at
the debates right so there you go to him
just like any other uh and and I think
Marion Williamson and RFK Jr would have
like a legitimate debate when they had
her on uh like there there was so much
screwing around you know was it like
Andrew Yang's Mike got cut off yeah do
you remember that yeah and he's just
going like
mouthing like nothing's happening I
explained that if it was Donald Trump
and they cut his mic he would lean over
and grab the other person excuse me
excuse me my microphone is off I need
that's Trump that's why Trump wins
because Trump would not let them silence
him and there's nothing they can do if
he if he's like Steps out of line and
says no I'm talking well that's the
thing he's polite to people or he's not
polite to people who aren't being polite
to him and so often that's what the
establishment depends upon they crap all
over everyone who's an outsider and
tries to stand up to them and then they
go oh sorry yes I'm sorry okay I'll go
along with it we saw this with
Republicans time and time again you're
racist you're a sexist home of your
homophobic you're terrible or they would
just ask them questions where that was
the subtext and they'd go I just want to
be very sensitive to your concern and I
want you to know I really do care about
you and your valleys in trouble like
you're an idiot shut up it's like great
that's they that's kind of what they
deserve well I Trump's not mean to
people who aren't mean to him no that's
what I'm saying in fact no no the when
it came to the bump stock ban when they
go to Trump and they say let's work
together he goes okay and then he agrees
with them if the Democrats went to Trump
and they said you're so smart your
policies are amazing we think you're
going to be the best here's what you
need to do who go absolutely I agree and
you would sign it in fact he actually
said in the interview with Tucker
recently he was talking about how Gavin
Newsom was so nice to him and the real
story is there Gavin Newsom understood
how to play Trump yeah you you'd be nice
to him you ask for things and he'll give
it to you and he did he got he here's
what I need for California okay sure you
know you flatter him I mean you know you
play the game a little bit but honestly
like I I was just going back and
watching some of those private primary
debates with Trump in 2015 2016. I mean
it was so great television and also
honestly gets the point of why the media
became what they became because they
were all in on it they I mean CNN and
MSNBC they would put him on all the time
he was on Morning Joe and calling in
from the bathroom he was on you know Don
Lemon all the time he was talking
everybody and they did it because they
would love to have him be the nominee
and then they knew he would lose to
Hillary and so they're like all right
great let's ride this it's great ratings
and then they get that shock on November
8th and and they don't know how to deal
with it but in that moment they were
they were all good for the for the TV
yeah oh yeah I guess Zucker felt
personally respect responsible at CNN
yeah so he was offended because like or
ashamed because there are people being
like they would come to him and say why
did you give him all this air time and
he was like we were making money and so
then he made it his mission to just
destroy Trump in the Press right yeah
and it's hilarious because all they did
was expose themselves as biased
destroyed whatever remaining credibility
they had and made people who already
like Trump like him a whole lot more now
what I find so hilarious about the
entire situation is that you're correct
that people who flatter Trump seem to
get ahead in some sense and the left
could have very easily played him in
that way but because their TDS was so
strong it was like this perfect storm
where this weakness of his couldn't
really be exploited by them because they
were too deranged they were too
histrionic over and there was freaking
out and screaming it's Donald Trump it's
like if you if you were just as
dishonest as you always are and tried to
flatter him you might have been able to
get some of the things done that you
wanted to get done but you're not
capable oh and I think one other thing
by Jeff Zucker because that's that's
what makes it so unique about Donald
Trump I mean Jeff Zucker and Donald
Trump go way back you know Donald Trump
made Jeff Zucker at NBC because of The
Apprentice it was a huge hit Jeff Zucker
had no hits before that when he ran NBC
he was Jeff Zucker was one of the many
media members who were at Donald Trump's
wedding to Melania in 2005. Katie Couric
was there Matt Lauer Barbara Walters you
go right on Down the Line Elton John
performed I mean he was part of that
world for so long I mean he was hosting
Saturday Night Live in 2015. he was he
was in that world he was hosting the
Celebrity Apprentice in 2015 and then he
left and gave Arnold Schwarzenegger a
chance to do it right before he
announced for running for president and
then to become the turncoat you know
these people thought they knew him they
thought he was what he was their friend
he was he was part of that world and
then he turned on him and that that I
think it it went became so personal for
so many of those people man Let's uh
let's jump to a news story we got this
one uh yeah you got I know you guys want
to talk about Bud Light we got a former
Anheuser-Busch executive slamming
inauthentic Bud Light for having lost
track of the consumer there's a bunch of
developments for one their restaurant
volume is decline uh has has dropped
34.7 percent
we're hearing that various different
sales metrics show a drop of like 17 in
general sales volume is decreased in
double digits and uh here's my favorite
latest development on the Bud Light
boycott story it is first I'd like to
bring you all back in time to April 13th
for this CNN article
Bud light's inclusive ad campaigns are
good for business experts
safe and then we get this masterpiece
Bud Light sales are falling but
Distributors say they're sticking by the
brand uh teen daysless shot and Chaser
oh you'll love to see it I love this
guys screenshot those two uh I should I
should actually just do this right now
I'm the first one of Jim Cramer byline
yeah right Jim Cramer by Bud Light
so they'll make statements like this
inclusive ad campaigns are good for
consumers okay this is circular yes if
an ad campaign is truly inclusive as in
it is maximally appealing to the largest
base possible then yes it's going to be
an effective ad campaign clearly okay
clearly Bud Lights ad campaign was not
inclusive right it was not inclusive
because they alienated their own viewers
so let me give you an example name an
incredibly controversial group of people
I don't want to be like lazy and say the
Irish the the Irish No Name a group
people generally let's say um antifa
antifa okay
so if a marketing but part of why this
might break down is because you can
almost actually see this happening but
if
The Firm said you know what we're going
to be really inclusive we're going to
include antifa and our next
advertisement you go we'll hold on a
second okay by including them you're
excluding everyone who takes issue with
them so inclusive does it mean welcoming
a new group right it means how are we
going to get the most possible people
right to be loyal to our brand and
here's and here's here's an important
distinction as it pertains to say
political ideology
there's a big divide in this country and
it's roughly down the middle in terms of
politics so you risk alienating half the
population by choosing so you stay away
from it yeah but then you can make the
argument about when it comes to race
well there's Millions hundreds of
millions tens of millions of people of
varying different racial backgrounds and
a tiny bit of racists so you know what
if we want to maximize our total market
share we go for a literal inclusive
strategy which is apolitical and just as
everybody's chill to have our beer
instead they go directly for the most
polarizing and divisive and and like
nails on a chalkboard personality and
then just gut their brand exactly they
didn't make it inclusive they made it as
exclusive as possible exactly let's push
everyone out outside of our small group
of people who feel a need to Virtue
signal to one another that we think this
is a beautiful woman definitely that's
what we're looking at here woman and
beautiful so sloppy so I I saw I forgot
who it was because I'd love to give him
credit it was on Twitter Twitter someone
basically came up with you want to
appeal to the trans Community okay
here's a here's an idea right okay
you're a Bud Light Factory and you've
got a person there they are a factory
worker and they're they're trans or a
little bit scared to come to work and
they get there and they're and their
friends welcome them in okay well there
now you've got an ad that's that's not
alienating it's maybe welcome to it but
they went in the most clunky you know
embarrassing way possible and yet talk
about the language experts say I mean
literally I know I know anytime a
headline has experts say just just
distrust it honestly experts say is the
blue check mark of uh news articles but
I will mention this I actually think
even an advertisement like that wouldn't
work for Bud Light because the consumers
would go this is obvious virtue
signaling they're trying to be awoke
brand and that's not who Bud Light is
generally marketing itself towards
that's not who buys Butler that's the
craziest thing about this leftist
ideology is that they're willing to earn
the entire house exactly just for the
sake of their ideology and looking like
they're doing the right thing and I
don't know that's going off for the
friends that's why I say it's not really
an ideologist it's a cult it's a chaotic
destructive force that has no end game
maybe the end game is destroying the
country maybe they're being wielded by
by evil people to destroy things but
that's all they do consume and Destroy
and and we talk about a person who
bought into the cult I mean part of the
problem with the Bud Light thing was the
also podcast with the VP of marketing
it's explaining why the brand that she
is a part of is bad essentially is why
it's too fratty and we have to change it
that that's your problem when you when
you pair that with the Dylan Mulvaney
video which was again I mean who is is
buying Bud Light because of that are
Dylan Mulvaney's fans buying Bud Light
because of that I can't even imagine
that anyone thought this was a good idea
oh my gosh and yet and this is what you
get well now that I think about it Tim
cast probably isn't doing enough to be
inclusive and to reach out to these
liberals so we're going to replace
Sheamus with what genk yuger of The
Young Turks you can't replace me then
your Stock's gonna go down a million
dollars I'll be like the Tucker Carlson
of Tim cast experts say it's actually
you might be good to be a great idea
experts say having to alienate his
entire viewer base yeah right telling
your customers telling your audience
telling your fans that uh they're bad
people tends not to work out for you
yeah shockingly enough shockingly enough
uh it's so bizarre but this is just what
happens right people don't understand
the brands that they're trying to create
advertisements for and sometimes they
can get away with it I remember last
year we had Libby Emmons here and we
were maybe this is a year and a half ago
now but we were watching these different
woke advertisements that candy companies
were doing it was a bunch of different
brands oh the M M's thing from Tucker
Carlson is that you're talking about oh
no no no I'm talking about the one where
the witch comes in and basically kills
the kid with magic but that's not
exactly what happens yes don't you
remember we're watching the commercial
and reviewing it this kid has like a
witch babysitter and she comes in and
she like the kid does something gender
non-conforming and so it was supposed to
be a woke commercial you might remember
this well we reviewed it on air and made
fun of it and we were looking at a
couple bow commercials but you know
sometimes Brands can sort of get away
with it because even though their their
product is a political the consumers
aren't going to Care all that much but
with Bud Light I mean you're really
talking about something that is marketed
generally again towards Friday dudes and
also Working Class People it is a cheap
beer it your audience is toxic
masculinity right that's that's such a
good point though because like so in
uncovered I write about something like I
call guilt journalism when you there I I
specifically cite there was a magazine
Cosmo that put on the cover this
gigantic obese woman and then just with
the headline this is healthy this is
healthy now for sure right if you want
to put on the headline you know want to
put this person on the cover okay but
what what are we seeing here what are we
doing well it's because they feel this
guilt over what they've done for decades
of putting real thin women on their
cover and what that has caused and so
now they feel this guilt it's like a
pre-cancellation we're going to just
we're gonna just get ahead of this and
and say oh no no no now this is healthy
now we're see we're the good people and
honestly in some ways that feels like
what that Bud Light marketing executive
was saying too it's like we're a bad
brand so let's let's become good now but
we feel guilty about what we've done
exactly well they wanted to court a
higher class of consumers that's a
general idea white men are bad right
working class men are bad right all of
the people who are considered toxically
masculine conservatives the Frat Boys we
we know what they're dog whistling when
they talk about this and so what do we
need well we need a trendy younger hip
viewer base you know people who would
have higher Social credit scores so to
speak and that's who we need to try to
Market to so we're going to spit in the
face of our current consumer Base by
marketing to them with something that we
are explicitly saying isn't for them
because what we're trying to say is this
brand is not for you anymore go away
do you remember Gillette you guys
remember the Gillette ad I'm sure when
that guy another great examples razors
came about right yes there's the part
where the dude sees the attractive woman
and he goes like Oh and he tries to walk
with the other guy stops him he's like
no don't don't talk don't talk to women
he's like women are gross bro no
actually Jeremy's raised I think it was
a Dollar Shave Club thing right yeah
Harry's Razors I'm sorry sorry cancel
their ads yeah but um that Gillette ad
too it was so ridiculous because
they took so rough and tumble play which
all of the psychological literature
shows is incredibly important and
necessary for the development of young
boys it portrays it as two little boys
just beating the crap out of each other
and the Two Dads at the grill going well
boys will be boys is if that's what real
life is right they took a gender studies
dissertation made it into an
advertisement and insulted their entire
viewer base because guess what like
those razors are for men they're male
raisers and I think this is a softer
repeat of that I don't even remember why
Jeremy made chocolate bars at this point
I just know that we have 2 000 of them
downstairs they're good they're actually
pretty good man they have four
ingredients it's like chocolate dried
milk powder and like organic sugar or
something nuts and cocoa butter
almonds what was it it was it was the
Hershey's did the candy bar commercial
with the Trans woman yep and then Jeremy
was like don't buy that chocolate
okay I will and so I bought two thousand
bars you're such a consumer Tim well I
think you know we we should legitimately
be supporting agreed these efforts so
the moment you know uh Jeremy's light or
whatever comes out right Brew We'll
order that too
um but this is this is the point you
should you should be supporting
companies that are clearly in support of
your values we are this this show was
sponsored by Public Square shout out to
them because we're huge fans you can go
on the app and you can find businesses
and it's awesome look in your area
figure out which businesses actually
care about your values and don't give
your money to Bud Light
that's great and then we win yeah well
for so long conservatives have been so
reluctant to do that one massive flaw
with the right people view this is a
strength it's not as much of a strength
as they think it is one massive law on
the right is this almost this this odd
desire not to alienate everyone right
and so the left will claim they don't
want to alienate people but then
obviously they shun anyone who steps out
of line even slightly and the right has
always said well we're just a home for
everyone who considers themselves a
non-leftist or or anti-leftist and so
because of that I think conservatives
have very much prided themselves on
being able to have conversations with
people they disagree with and that's all
well and good right but I think for a
while there was this stigma that if you
as a conservative didn't tolerate
everything the left was doing then you
were just as bad as the left and I'm
glad conservatives are stepping out of
that saying you know what we can and we
should boycott these Brands and there
actually is something we can do about
this it is weird how the what was it I
was what was it
um stick sex and Hammer put out he made
a meme and it was so amazing and it said
the actual political party uh let me let
me pull this up shout out to Sticks I
got to pull this up it was too funny uh
and then uh let me I don't want to ruin
the joke so I'm but uh let me let me let
me get it I'm scrolling I'm scrolling
I'll find it it's in here so I retweeted
it because it was hilarious here you go
check this out it says the two-party
system summed up Republican paralyzed
goat Democrat diseased rat so instead of
the you know the elephant and the
jackass or whatever it's uh the
Republican paralyzed goat I think
perfectly sums up what the Republican
party is they get startled and then just
lock up and then fall over and the
Democrats are a diseased rat there you
go and and I mean I'm not the
individuals not the people
I'm not trying to call people that I'm
saying the political parties and what
they represent like the Republican being
a paralyzed goat is just too perfect
yeah like the diseased rat thing is like
I don't know whatever but the
Republicans are paralyzed goat and
you're trending on Twitter
I retweeted sticks I will tweet this out
I hereby agree with this it's the party
thing yeah yeah the parties this is what
they represent but really like I said
the Democrat disease red thing is kind
of like hey okay the Republicans has
paralyzed goats hits the nail on the
hammer too perfectly that's what they
are yeah something Starling comes up
okay and they fall over
paralyzed goat shout out 6X and Amber
666 that was a really good one
but that but that's why it's it's been
so difficult to win culture War battles
however disaffected liberals have
aligned themselves with the Republican
Party exactly and now there is for
Republicans a fighting chance so I still
look at it like this we were at the
Turning Point USA event
we are the only ones there see except
for Steve Bannon who weren't wearing we
weren't wearing suits everybody's up on
stage wearing some kind of suit yeah and
then we show up and we're just like I
don't know wearing what we wear looking
like schlubs yeah well I was a black tie
event yeah sure so this this is what I
think these young conservative types
these you know look man if you go to a
bunch of high school kids wearing a suit
and you're like hello there fellow kids
they're gonna be like yeah okay what
well you got to be a right you got to be
like relaxed and Casual you know there's
clearly a realignment I mean it's
happening I I I how many people that are
they're fans of the show probably you
know consider themselves potentially
conservative but not Republicans I think
that there's there's a lot of people
that that are in the culture today that
are seeing that where the left is going
and saying that's not me you know I
don't know exactly where I am right now
but I I mean I think about it you talk
about like you know the right could be
talk to anyone right I think that's
that's a good philosophy I agree with
that I talk to anyone and the left right
now is not just the right husband ideas
they have dumb ideas you know
conservatives are stupid but these
people are dangerous yeah and I think
that's a huge change that's actually the
and it's coming from the media too I
write I describe them as anti-speech
activists these people that should be
about free speech and allowing a free
flow of ideas on social media or
wherever are now saying no no these
people are dangerous and I actually
think that that young people see that
and say I'm not I'm not going to be a
part of that that's not it's who I am
it's the cult versus the not cult I want
to mention something here too because
the media did spend a lot of time
talking about how much it cared about
Free Speech it's really easy to care
about Free Speech when you're the only
voice but as soon as the Advent of the
internet and your average person being
able to voice your own opinions all of a
sudden we got all of these specials and
different news outlets about
disinformation and what we need to do to
ensure that hate speech doesn't spread
online the whole utility of television
in the present era where the internet
exists is I get to talk at you and you
don't get to say anything back right
that's what it's for so we shouldn't be
shocked that the vast majority of India
individuals and Legacy Media don't
believe in free speech because their
platform is fundamentally anti-free
speech it's I get to say what I want and
I don't hear anything back from you so
we're working on a bunch of new projects
obviously we're looking for talent and
we've been talking to some individuals
who are like um and I don't want to be
involved in political stuff and I'm like
look the show that we're launching is
not political in any way it's a it's
totally its own Standalone thing and so
we start working on this and I'll keep
the details vague for now but the
individual said that they started
getting threats of violence insults and
attacks and I was like did you get any
of that from anyone associated with the
right or like disaffected liberals or
like no of course not yeah and I was
like and do you agree with all of these
people it's like no of course not and
I'm like isn't it crazy that someone
like Sheamus who is Catholic staunchly
pro-life can sit here and disagree with
me or Ian or whatever and he's like one
he's one of our best friends we laugh
together he's on the show consistently
there's no beef right there's none but
if if it comes to the left you disagree
on one issue you're route you're far
right you're bad you're evil this is
literally Hitler yeah literally Hitler
this is The Joe Rogan thing that's so
fascinating to me I mean Joe Rogan is a
guy who's a if he's supporting any
politician it's Bernie Sanders you know
it's this is the as Progressive as it
can get and yet why does the left hate
him and the corporate media hate him is
because he's impeding on their power and
because he's willing to have
conversations I mean I describe him as
an information maximalist and the media
is now full of information minimalists
they want the minimum amount of
information out there for the public to
consume because really they just
fundamentally distrust people they
distrust their own audience and they
distrust the average American and and
the right it is now all of a sudden in
this position of being oh no actually
you know let's let's get ideas out there
now not the right but Bill Maher and Joe
Rogan these are people that just have a
fundamental disagreement with the way
the left has shifted towards this
anti-free speech platform and I think
the other side of that too though is is
also the left has gotten so crazy in a
lot of their core beliefs now don't with
they don't stand up so to intellectual
scrutiny so if they had their ideas
challenged on social media on these news
programs and people are exposed to one
side and the other side and and the
actual facts like men can't be women men
don't have uteruses you know if we truly
have an actual open debate pretty much
ninety percent of everything they
believe is gonna is gonna be obliterated
yep that's why they don't want to come
on the show yep and every every polite
invite gets turned down we will pay for
your travel we will fly you first class
we will get a car waiting for you a guy
holding up a sign with your name on it
we'll bring you out there will be a
filet mignon medium rare oscar style
right on this table it was great service
and you can say whatever you want and
they're like no wait
while insulting Tim across from it I'm
saying for leftists we gotta we gotta
pull out of the stocks well that's red
carpet come on down and they're like no
and then you get the grifter ones who
are like just willing to lie cheat and
steal for fame and they're like oh come
on it's like not you yeah you know we
know what your game is I'm talking about
the actual personalities we're talking
about leftist politics and policies
Jimmy door came on but we're big fans of
Jimmy Dore he was a he was a regular on
Tucker too right this is thing like
there are some people that I think are
are willing to do it themselves and are
willing to have that exchange but
they're just so afraid of the backlash
they're so afraid of what a few people
yelling at them on Twitter will feel
like that that they don't understand
that that is such an unrepresentative
situation when it comes to what your
actual fans what people that actually
like you what would they would get out
of that that I I they're so warped and
living in this bubble of Twitter which
is you know as polls have shown two
percent of all Americans account for 90
of tweets about politics I mean it is
it's it's unrepresentative and listen I
spend way too much time Twitter myself I
love it I hate that I love it you know
I'm not representative of this but I try
to have some self-awareness that this is
not real life that people who you know
love me on Twitter or hate me on Twitter
it's a very small cross-section but I I
I think it's becoming real life that's
the issue that's starting to feed into
it yeah well that it has been that this
you know Twitter isn't real life was
prominent six seven years ago because
people were hyper online but now there's
no middle anymore yeah now it's to the
point where
it really does I like the craziest thing
is I I've had people come to me and be
like oh hey your Tim pool I follow you
on Twitter and I'm like oh do you watch
the show and they're like I should
follow you on Twitter man really okay so
it's like Twitter's influence has become
pronounced which is probably why Elon
Musk was like I have to buy this thing
yeah well I mean a lot of what people
end up deciding to talk about or report
about or discuss on their podcast is
based on what they see trending on
Twitter so it's an incredibly powerful
tool now a lot of people don't realize
is that well Twitter in terms of its
user base is not the furthest left
platform it certainly leans to the left
to the point where if it were a state
for example it would be you know pretty
solidly blue and
a lot of Corporations will look to the
kind of reception they are getting on
Twitter from their advertisement
campaigns to determine whether they
should shift course
and they're getting an incredibly biased
sample and many of them haven't realized
that in the past so you'll get a bunch
of people tweeting at you saying well
this campaign was offensive etc etc all
right well you're you're getting a
biased sample there but corporations
will still make changes based on that
very biosample let's jump to the story
from the Daily Mail refund the police
Portland finally launches Crackdown on
crime after defunding the police by 15
million dollars as it hires more
District Attorneys and investigators to
tackle spiraling car and retail theft
all right how long until you you think
it is until liberals starts saying we
were always in support of the police
it's the conservatives that hated police
whether they want to refund the police I
hope they kept the receipt because I
think a lot of those cops ain't coming
back you drive them out of their jobs
you make it as difficult as possible for
them to do it this was their plan the
whole time yep they got all the
conservative leaning cops to quit and
now that none of them would touch the
Department's a 10-foot pole they're
going to hire only the people who
support their crackpot ideas between
that and covet you know between the
vaccine days and all the other things
that drove that you know changed the
force out of this Kim Fox in Chicago big
prosecutor wouldn't prosecute Jesse
Smollett was a Soros funded D.A which I
know you're not supposed to say but that
is just a fact
she's not running for a re-election I I
think we're going to see a shift here
and part of the shift I would imagine is
because they got to get this shift going
before 2024 because this is a winning
issue for the Republicans yes but the
cops are going to be pro-anti for now
we've already seen it happen and there's
a video of a guy backing away from
antifa and they're threatening him with
weapons and the cops grab the victim and
arrest him wow maybe maybe I don't know
the full context yeah but it's a guy
backing up saying get away from me get
away from me and then the cop apologizes
to an antifa woman so I'm sorry ma'am
what it gotta be man because if if they
if they're bringing these police
officers back in these blue areas these
cops are risking their their livelihoods
by just doing their jobs they get
charged for arresting the wrong person
by one of these liberal DA's until they
get dragged through the media they're
going to get charged they're gonna be
convicted they're gonna get thrown in
jail so they got to be on the same time
what happens when Portland says all
right we're going to be hiring 500 new
cops and all the applicants are antifa
I'm not kidding they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna be the ones to show
up and be like yes I'll be a cop and
then basically a far left extremist gang
puts on the badge and can go around
doing whatever they want with government
sanction
that's that's it it's definitely
possible part of me hopes that their
ideology their ideology would select
against it I understand that they don't
have principles but they hate cops so
much that you think that would get them
pushed out of their Social Circles nope
they'd be like they'll have a direct
action meeting and they'll say we're
going to take over the department we're
gonna we're gonna take that those badges
and then we'll control they're gonna go
yay just like when the BLM activists
cheered for the police arresting the guy
from his own home they say the police
are bad and then they go yeah and call
the cops and cheer for them when the
cops show up Yep they're posting on
Twitter arrest them arrest them arrest
these people
they want they want that power I thought
you were about to say that wait wait
what happens when they're all trans that
was where we were going with it but I
mean but a lot of them would be right
that's the thing about the ideology yeah
no have you seen there was a I think
James Lindsay posted this they're
already wearing rainbow armbands and I'm
like this is really weird everything's
changing yeah or you know kind it's
changing but in many ways staying the
same it's like it's like history rhyming
it's not a red armband it's a rainbow
armband but it basically represents the
same kind of authoritarian pressures
they just got all the the colors covered
that's right the rainbow yeah so they're
all all the entire spectrum of
authoritarianism yeah in one armband yep
yep it exists on a spectrum Tim I mean
it does but yeah I guess the issue was
uh
Portland's been collapsing I think uh
what is it they had like a famous
restaurant shut down because the crime
is so bad there's a bunch of cafes are
shutting down
I don't know what they thought was gonna
happen or would any of these studies
thought was going to happen and so for
me I'm kind of like good I don't care
yeah but it's the problem is the
aftermath yeah when they start hiring
far left extremists we're seeing the
story of the mass Exodus from California
and we're like aha look at that you know
moderate and right-leaning people are
fleeing going to Florida and Texas and
it's like yeah you know what that means
right most many of them are probably
cops many of them worked in government
law or like law enforcement things like
that now the left is going to open up
those positions and make appointments of
far left extremists into those seats of
government California may lose a lot of
people but now they're going to create a
lot of far left extremists in positions
of authority and power yeah yeah the
good ones I mean I'm in Texas myself and
uh you know it's a big story right now
obviously of people coming it's like
you're right the good ones are coming
right the ones who are uh who are open
to coming to Texas open to come into
Tennessee or wherever uh then you get
left with even even Bluer in some cases
obviously it's going to make Texas a
little bit more purple than it was I
mean I'm in Dallas so it's already be
pretty pretty 50 50 red blue but yeah
what's the effect to be in in the LA and
San Francisco which is already just
struggling beyond belief we barely get
coverage of it there's this crazy video
I saw today where a guy it's a homeless
guy in San Diego who's got a tent and
he's got a knife it looks like some kind
of like buck knife and he's screaming
how he's going to kill a woman or some
random woman and then he just stabs the
wall as hard as he can it's kind of
nothing happens but he's screaming the
dude filming is like every day he does
this he threats he's going to kill
somebody and like the cops won't do
anything oh my God why would they what
are they going to do about it what are
they going to do shop and arrest the guy
and then they just open the door and let
him go again it's it's a cultural and
social Decay yeah that's it I wonder I
got to be honest what's causing all of
the mental issues that surround
homelessness
not every homeless person is mentally
ill no some of them are vagabonds by
choice but a lot of these people who see
sleeping on the city streets there's
something wrong upstairs what's causing
this Spike you know what I mean yeah
it's like a combination of mental health
issues and also drug policy yeah it's
that also I mean look man is not living
the way he is meant to live in this
society and that produces negative
outcomes physically and mentally
yeah I agree with that I saw your Tweet
today about about you know kids what's
causing people that are young people to
yeah I tweeted not want to be who they
are I mean that that's this is a huge
problem well I was just thinking about
it in a general sense I tweeted we need
to start asking ourselves why young
people are so desperate to be someone
else instead of themselves and it's
gotten like in 9 000 retweets or
whatever the funny thing though is the
left responses
immediately talking about trans issues
right I found that and I was just like
I'm just I was speaking generally kids
wanting to be a famous YouTuber like
wanting to be Mr Beast or whatever
my point is this some people have
latched on that and been like every
child looks up to somebody and wants to
do that but I'm like look I am outright
saying why are there people who are
dying their skin why are there people
who who are trans why are there people
who are trans species why are there
people who create fake personas why are
the people who use different names why
why don't they just want to develop who
they are and someone responded to a
conservative person was like
it's normal for kids to want to be
someone else and then I'm just like is
that a projection because when I was a
kid I didn't want to be anybody else
that didn't exist in my mind I was just
I just was what I was there's this viral
video from a show called the good doctor
where it's about it's a show about an
autistic doctor I've never seen it and
the patient is a transgender little boy
who has testicular cancer and you find
that at the end of the scene but he says
something like he says he's autistic so
he's like you're a boy because you have
X Y chromosomes not xx and then the kid
says how did you know you were supposed
to be a boy other than uh with uh you
know other than biology and he goes
that's your your question makes no sense
I'm not supposed to be anything I am a
boy and I was like
that's a perfect line you're not
supposed to be anything you're supposed
to be who you are what you are why are
people so desperate young people so
desperate to not be themselves I mean a
lot of them a lot of the mechanisms that
we have for
self-discovery and for emotional
development and Social Development have
gone by the wayside you know we don't go
outside and play anymore as kids we
don't really interact everything that we
do is on in apps through social media
we're filtered through these programs
that have algorithms that shape our
world and they're programmed to re to
reward you and give you a dopamine hit
based on certain triggers yeah so our
entire Society has shifted from
something that allows you to be able to
grow and have that self-discovery
process and figure out who you are and
reward you for being an individual and
just being yourself to making you want
and again these children are
impressionable your brain doesn't fully
fully form and develop until you're 25.
so we have these uh this this this group
of millions of kids who don't go through
this process in their entire life
experiences geared toward wanting to to
please an algorithm which is essentially
making you want to be what you see on
the screen instead of figuring out who
the hell you are absolutely getting
plastic surgery to look like Snapchat
filters young young women are developing
fake Tourette's Syndrome yeah because
they want to emulate what they see on
these apps and yet social contagion with
respect to transgenderism is completely
dismissed there are kids who are
literally pretending to have Tourette's
there has not been some massive uptick
in tourettes and yet when we see a
massive uptick in gender confusion that
couldn't possibly be social contagious
we were always that way we say society
allows them to say it but it may not be
pretending they may act no social
contagion doesn't mean preventing him
right yeah they're trying to be
Tourette's some of these young women are
actually developing a social
issue and they're getting Tourette's
Syndrome from watching prominent
Tourette's personalities are coming from
with inside the home too you talk a lot
about fabulous homes but yeah um you
know it's a piece that I wrote for
timcastnews.com
[Laughter]
there was a a study from 1994 that just
resurfaced that found that 53 of mothers
of boys who identify as trans have their
own psychological issues including
depression and Borderline Personality
Disorder so there's it's not even just
uh social contagion I think is a large
part of it but some of this is being
directed from within these these
children's own homes because their
parents have their own issues that they
haven't sorted and that's even before
social media right 1994. I mean I I
agree with you I think social media has
a huge factor and not just because of
the incentives of it but because you go
from maybe you grew up wanting to be
famous or you wanted to be you know
successful but now you want to be
special and you're doing it in a way
that is performative it's it's public in
in a way that never existed before I
mean I I you know whether it's the media
whether it's kids growing up the the
incentives of of getting feedback from
friends from Family from fans in in the
moment it's very hard to I can't even
imagine growing up in a society where
you are living in public and and you
have in your mind the potential of is
this the thing that's going to make me
famous or special and and you're doing
it on Instagram you're doing all these
platforms that that have that ability
and then you're also doing it with all
these the the normal pressures that you
have with being a kid and being at
school and dealing with things and then
and even with when it comes to to
bullying and the again the normal things
that you would just go through in
elementary school in junior high and
high school there's not an off switch
anymore because of these platforms you
go home you're still dealing with it
online through DMs yeah other people
tweeting and tick-tocking and sharing
your post it never goes away so we have
a entire culture that's sick right now
and again when we talk about things like
school shootings this is part of the
reason we've created a culture that is
completely completely ill and and needs
a little little bit of reformation we've
taken God out of people's lives we've
taken the meaning out of people's lives
by devaluing the family structure and
what role families should play in our
lives and all of it has an impact and
it's all planned out in these really
weird ways as we sit here and scratch
our heads trying to figure out what's
going on because we're too afraid not us
but in general people are afraid to
address the real issues yeah yeah well I
think another massive problem is just
how much we have forgotten what nature
is in and of itself so wealth allows you
to insulate yourself from nature and
it's also allowed us to insulate
ourselves from our own nature we think
of it as something external that's
nature it's out there but you're a human
being you also have a nature to you and
so not only do we not know how to combat
the threats that exist in the outside
world we've insulated ourselves from we
have actually forgotten how to combat
the elements of our own nature that are
nefarious you know I remember ended up
that scene in the movie Snatch you guys
ever see that one with um Brad Pitt uh
Brad Pitt's in it uh who else is in it
Jason Statham's in it there's a lot of
people that are in it and there's that
scene where Jason Statham Statham is
with his buddy and then his buddy says
like you can't drink milk because it's
out of sync with Evolution and he's like
what do you mean and he's like humans
didn't evolve to drink milk they doubted
it later so it's not properly attuned to
like our bodies and digestion you
shouldn't drink it and I'm thinking
about that as it pertains to Modern
social media humans this technology is
out of sync with Evolution humans
survived by being certain ways like
Community Family things like that we
certainly want to do away with bad
things and and keep uh hold on to the
good things and the good ideas but now
we have this machine that is feeding us
a feedback loop of dopamine hits and
other psychotic garbage and it's making
young people literally go insane yeah
and I have to say I think you know it's
been a problem longer than this but
covid made it worse I I think that the
the after effects of covet I've got this
this theory of this column I'm thinking
about which is that basically covet
explains everything over the last couple
years I think you know whether it's
January 6th or any I think I think that
there's so much of of what is the is the
after effect of those insane year and a
half two years I mean in some people's
cases people that I know it it remains
to this day that it will have permanent
damage on on our culture that in ways
that I don't think we even fully
comprehend that that in disrupting the
nature of what we were supposed to be
doing of what we're supposed to of how
we're supposed to live and yet we all
went along with this for you know some
people longer than others I I think that
this integration of the family may be
the the like the worst apocalyptic
scenario people don't realize of course
we talk about oh zombies meteor strikes
world war three it's like dude families
breaking up could be worse than all of
those things no it is because the family
is the most foundational building block
of any social structure it's all built
Atop The Family if I I I I feel like
because there's no communal family
structure you end up with rapid crime my
neighbor doesn't know me doesn't care
about me I am meaningless to their
existence so why not exploit that you
end up with crime going crazy in these
cities
yeah exactly well part of the beauty of
family and part of the beauty again of
what is built into us what is built into
our own nature is the people closest to
us are people we are literally
biologically hardwired to want to fight
for and protect in a way that we are not
strangers you can have a very
good-hearted police officer who
genuinely cares about you and who's even
well trained he is not going to have the
same internal motivations to fight for
you the way that your brother or your
father will and what we've attempted to
do because we've forgotten our nature is
try to universalize the protection of
one another well we'll just build a
great big system that does it and we
won't have to rely on these connections
it doesn't work I'm not saying that
having a legal system doesn't work that
having police departments doesn't work
but what I am saying is the thing that
works the best is the family in the
family unit and we've tried to Outsource
so much of what it does best that we're
just failing at all of those things and
now people don't even end up you know
having families anymore close
connections to them because they believe
they can rely on these institutions
instead and they don't end up getting
the same results I would just say I not
to be all glass half full which I I do
get into occasionally of being maybe too
optimistic about this stuff but I do
think conversations like this are
encouraging and the fact that these
conversations are successful on
platforms that people may be finding
other junk food and yet can have can
have real deep conversations can be part
of a community even if it's a digital
one can it can is actually a sign and
again I know we started with Tucker
Carlson the demise of Fox News it's
another sign that corporate media is
junk and that conversations like this
are going to win out and and actually
connect with people in ways that it
should these are the kinds of com you
know connections that people should be
having if you guys ever seen A Bronx
Tale no I've never seen it you have seen
it but someone posted a clip on Twitter
today and I watched it I've not seen the
movie but this clip was incredible it's
I think the movie is basically about
like uh Italian mafia in the what like
the 40s or something I don't know I
think so what is it 30s and so what
happens is this guy is eating dinner
with this kid he's taking this is the
mob bus and a bunch of bikers were up to
this bar and they're being loud he walks
he walks over to check out what's going
on and the the like the owner is arguing
with these bikers saying you're not
dressed properly you can't be in here
and then the leader of the biker gang
looks at the mob boss and he's like look
man we just want a couple beers and
we'll be out of here we'll be out of our
way and goes spoken like a gentleman
give these men give these men their
beers and I was like look at that that's
like honorable then they immediately
shake the beers up and spray the
bartender and then he walks in and says
okay now that was wrong you need to
leave and then the guy the the bike the
biker guy says like I'll I'll tell you
when the F I'm leaving so the mob box
walks over the door and then locks it he
turns around and he goes now you just
can't leave and then the the door opens
and the guys come in and start just like
beating the crap out of the the bikers
I'm not a big fan of how they
mercilessly beat these guys but it got
me thinking about how we used to handle
things if some dude showed up not
dressed properly and were kind of loud
and obnoxious but we're acting like
gentlemen we're like the beers aren't by
all means have a beer we're here to get
along you were nice to me have a nice
day but then when you cross that line we
say no to that
I was thinking about that because what
do we have now I'm watching a video of a
woman in a shopping in like a Target or
whatever just like beating some woman as
they're like stealing stuff and
everyone's just standing there filming
or running away and I'm like man what a
contrast to that scene from A Bronx Tale
where they're like we'll be nice to you
if you're nice to us but if you cross
the line we're going to drag you out of
here by your hair and then tell you to
leave knock your bikes over I mean the
scene's amazing but it's very very
different these days isn't it we we let
criminals run rampant everyone's too
scared to get involved and I think maybe
it's kind of obvious a lot of people the
government will arrest you yes if you
try to defend yourself you might get
shot in the ass
well yeah you might get shot I mean it's
I'm not jumping in a fight yeah I'm not
I wouldn't be the one that's standing
there recording but I mean you literally
have to and it is sad that we're here
but you have to think twice before you
intervene in certain conflicts
especially if you're in an area like New
York where you're trying to protect your
store from somebody who's robbing you
with a weapon and you shoot him and
you're the one that gets arrested
exactly and so this brings us to a point
where it's not just that we lack
civility it's that our social
institutions are actively anti-civility
when you do something to try to protect
and uphold the social order by
preventing crime you get in trouble for
that
yep
wasn't that kind of a core tenet though
of like this modern progressivism is the
idea of deconstruction yep they want to
deconstruct America deconstruct these
systems that have been established but
there is no indication of anything that
they're supposed to replace it with well
I've said this before and I won't launch
into my my whole explanation for why I
put it this way but leftism is social
Decay that's what it is I mean societies
break down because things tend to over
time we're a fallen species and leftism
is the ideological rationalization we
give to our abdication to uphold our
institutions the chaos is the point all
right let's go to super chats if you you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com and click join
us so that you can watch the members
only uncensored portion of the show we
got a crazy story for you guys in the
uncensored portion about a lawmaker who
wants to remove certain language from a
law that protects children and I'm Gonna
Keep It family friendly but uh yeah it's
not going to be so family friendly on
the uncensored portion of the show but
let's read those super chats we got
essay federale who says Tim last night
Max was Max Reddick whose Super Chat you
read before mine he cast shade on
crowder who did nothing wrong I see a
Super Chat like that and I'm gonna push
back we need people like Steven and you
thanks for giving air time to Dylan
Radigan that that rant from Dylan
Radigan was epic you know that one for
back in the day no I I love Dylan though
where he's like the Democrats are just
kicking the can down the road
Republicans are burning it down while
the country is being extracted he's like
they are taking 10 trillion dollars and
sending it overseas and did he say this
on MSNBC yeah yeah yeah that's awesome
Dylan was was one of my favorite people
that I worked with back I mean I didn't
work with him but I was a media reporter
super smart guy ended up getting
involved I think in uh with marijuana
Hydroponics and farming yeah yeah really
interesting dude yeah he's cool dude I
don't know where he's at these days no
you know I don't know I think I still
follow him on Twitter yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Biden's brain
is broken and strained a great unifier
treating half the country with disdain
billions to Ukraine he were his words
equal a migraine if he's to remain we'll
see him grab his chest in pain fjb there
you go little rat
Wendy casker says longtime member keep
on keeping on really appreciate the
Super Chat grafti says buck buck we're a
big fan of the chickens thank you very
much
all right what do we got here
Doug Ripley says sorry if I asked the
last two nights but what do you think
Fox does next logically Waters to eight
McAllen back to seven if given it uh
given into the spirit of the age Jenner
Caitlyn Jenner that's funny uh I gotta
say well I mean I Jesse Waters back to
eight makes sense uh I would not put
Martha McCallum back to seven I think
you got to do another another opinion
person there at seven and uh who will it
be I don't know I mean I I will have to
say a shout out to my friend will Cain
who I think is great um will is uh is a
frequent fill-in for Tucker and I think
he does a good job maybe a little bit
more in the Tucker Camp than they would
like so I don't know if that's the
direction they go and you got Brian
comead holding it down not doing so well
on the ratings but uh he's around
right on all right Brad says is Steve
related to author John krakauer I've got
I've gotten that a bunch no uh same last
name which is a weird last name but uh
no love into the wild but not related
Justin and pias says Ian is going to
leave you for Alex Stein's show
I think he already did I think that's
literally where he is right now
he said he's never coming back yeah he
said uh Adrian is the new Ian get it no
I know people in chat even like dude I
like Ian this shiny new hat and stuff
yeah
all right Doug Ripley says Tim heard
from a little birdie Steve deese gave
you a screener of Nefarious when he did
IRL have you seen it one of the best
movies I've seen in a long time should
be PG-13 not R get well soon Steve
um uh people here watched it and Sheamus
is like we gotta go see it yeah I heard
it I heard it was really good I've heard
good things I've heard really good
things actually so uh but yeah I think
we should go see it we'll figure it out
no dude let's do it
all right
let's grab another one Charlie Char
Dietz says tonight's views on Fox will
be lower because many didn't know Tucker
was gone until they tuned in last night
that's right so the ratings will be even
lower tonight oh my God it's going to
drop down before it gets back up again I
mean I think that you know Monday's
ratings weren't terrible but I think
that's because everyone expected Tucker
to be there right exactly and now now
they're oh man the key demo views are
gonna be like 50. it's gonna be bad look
this was it was really bad for them in
November 2020 it bounced back up but
partially because of Tucker I I don't
know what helps them back up crazy
self-inflicted wound yeah
Guardsman says even with no current job
Turner Carlson is still competing in the
same time slot yup and getting more
views uh good for him good troll the
Twitter Network can't slow that man down
Sean McWilliams says Tucker invite to
timcast IRL that is a no-brainer we have
already reached out to Tucker's team and
said uh we would love to have Tucker on
the show be fantastic
um we'll see what happens you know we've
invited lots of people on the show you
know they don't come on the show what
are you gonna do
elon's been invited several times
it is what it is
all right let's grab another Super Chat
essay federally says down with the
monarchy go with schedule F Trump 20
Infinity
came's ojeev says CSS glitch was perfect
opportunity for we need a complete and
total shutdown of the post millennial
until we figure out what the hell is
going on
uh oh Libby
cssa are on one of your articles
alone okay that's not her fault I love I
love that though it's like we we read a
lot of post-millennial so there'll be
something and I'll be like you can't say
that and then they'll go and change it
like no he's right we can't say there
was one where they called uh child sex
changes gender affirming care and I was
like what are you guys doing it's like
and they're like you're right actually
here's what I said the right will say
child genital mutilation the left will
say gender affirming care and I'm like I
don't need to use any hyperbolic
language child sex change operation yeah
literally what it is
that's it you know but I understand why
the right wants to use the terminology
they do and I totally understand what
the left is trying to use their
terminology everyone's trying to win a
political battle Yeah because you can't
actually change sex like your biological
sex can't be changed
it's like I actually so I think if
conservatives go to a regular person and
say they're mutilating children's
genitals that person will reject that
notion and say no you're crazy yeah if
you say child sex change they'll be like
what
it's a it's a it's a more neutral it's
like the literal academic term for what
it is and plus if you put you put child
before anything it's going to get
people's attention I think that's
honestly why the issue has become such a
hot button issue and and a winning issue
for the right is because it went from
sex change operation to child sex change
well to affirming care yeah yeah there's
a funny meme from 4chan where this
person said when they were a kid they
loved the movie Predator so they so
being young and wanting to play on play
video games online they made their user
tag the child predator and then started
trying to add their friends and like
nobody would respond yeah it's a funny
meme
Christopher Fisher says I keep hearing
you talk about crypto and blockchain
have you considered have uh considered
to bring on Charles hoskinson founder of
cardano and co-founder of ethereum he
was asked recently in his podcast if
he'll go on your show and he said he
would if he was invited I think we
invited him a long time ago directly and
then I don't know what happened so
I don't know I don't do booking
Cassandra does I thought he was gonna I
talk about crypto a lot are you going to
start Tim coin I'd love to buy in never
agamemnon's gym bag says Bud keep in
mind that the upcoming Bud earnings
report is for quarter one the protest
was in quarter two so the effects won't
show in this report don't let them
Gaslight you and say the boycott isn't
working that's right we can already see
that it is
Mohave 26 says well Tucker Carlson
becoming independent help him to reach
more undecided voters and hopefully
convince them to vote conservative
Maybe
maybe not
it's a good question I mean I I
Fox News is a giant platform but Tucker
has enough Avenues to reach people that
it's it's not going to have a problem if
he can work out the deal which obviously
is up in the air every day it feels like
something else is happening obviously no
one thought he'd be able to put a video
out tonight based on his contract
clearly that's not a violation of a
contract so he didn't say anything
though right he just he was very careful
uh he didn't say anything about why he
left but if he can actually get his
voice out sooner than later I don't
think he's having a problem convincing
anyone of anything I just want to point
out that Luke has been spamming the chat
just ragging on Sheamus I know not such
a little baby every single time I'm on
this show I could look I can always
count on him to watch me appreciate it
Luke Matthew Schneider says since people
are boycotting Anheuser Bush wouldn't it
also be helpful to boycott or protest
Busch Gardens in Williamsburg Virginia
and Tampa Florida I'm sure they're
making tons of money from their
amusement parks I don't know if we need
to protest it sounds like work this is
the easiest culture War battle ever
because it's literally just by a
different beer not doing something yeah
you're gonna do anything just like yeah
go when you go to the store get cores
instead of Bud and then you win it's
easy
there we go infernal Saxon says run
Roberto Jr on the Democratic ticket
so um for cast brew coffee
we uh
I I want to be careful what I say I
think I think we've uh sold way more
than we expected I'll put it that way of
Roberto Jr's arise with Roberto Junior
breakfast blend and it's because
everyone's just they love Roberto Jr
he's our he's our rooster okay and we
raise them he's Roberto's son you know
some people say he's on a throne he did
not build wow yeah very strong words but
uh that that one is selling like hot
cakes so we're we officially put in the
order we've got the uh decaf is
currently underway sleepy Joe
I love that sleepy Joe is our is our
decaf blend it's a dark roast and I
think we're doing unwoke is the decaf
light roast
yes yeah
that's right and it was from sleeping
our Discord members helped with those
names so sleepy Joe that's a really good
very good name for decaf to be honest
I don't think there is a single better
name for a political decaf brand I I
don't think you could come up with
something
yeah uh and then we have stand your
grounds oh man I think that one's a
medium roast
Sandy's got Roberto Junior on it he's a
little picture of him and he's yelling
he's Roberto's a good dude you know it's
got an era 15. nope nope just as uh just
as look what makes the rooster Noble is
that without weapons they will run full
speed to their deaths to save their hens
it's Beast someone like a predator shows
up the rooster will charge it knowing it
will die if it gives the hens a few
moments to to flee and get to safety and
everybody's always ragging on chickens
like they're scared it's like a kitten
roosters are brave man and this is it is
crazy to me because anybody who has
chickens knows roosters will attack you
yeah they're not they're not scared at
all they're they're kind of stupid
exactly don't come at me bro principled
I mean that maybe this is a good like uh
symbol for our discussion about our
culture it used to be like it used to be
considered a powerful Noble holy symbol
right the chicken and the you know the
rooster and roosters were on like a lot
of uh a lot of flags and iconography
were roosters and that's why I'm like
we're taking rooster back baby but think
about
human males fleeing in these videos like
a woman is getting beaten in a Target
and the guy's like I don't want to be
involved then you look at a rooster and
it's like I might die but I'm going to
try and save my hens and then it runs
full speed into a fox's mouth it's like
wow the Chad rooster yeah the soyjack
human I'm sorry I gotta stop I have a
problem I don't need goats we don't need
uh donkeys or we just need the roosters
roosters are legit man and chickens are
funny too they do their thing they give
us eggs they're good stuff principal
Paladin of the great Pope tato says the
followers of the birth of Bert the
Craven are worshiping a false idol
Sheamus is prophesized to lead us to
glory in the Church of the Sacred Spud
past basket
this is just listen you gotta get in the
Discord oh is this what they're going on
about yeah is this what they're listen
um I don't like the potato labels
they're very offensive to me and I've
told you guys before but I just I think
the more I tell you the more you do it
so I'm just gonna have to embrace it I
love the potatoes says Sheamus does
Luke's chair smell like Trump
derangement syndrome oh it smells way
grosser than that yeah I can tell you
about Luke would you get a Super Chat
and it would be like that one time Trump
saved that box of puppies from the fire
was great and Trump would be like but we
don't know if he didn't put him in there
maybe put those puppies in the fire and
you know the report I'm just kidding
Luke no we're not he's at home going
we're making fun of you for real by the
way by the way Luke my name is going to
be placed under this chair
we are changed as Luke gang strong
puking Potato Man weak wait did he say
Luke gang strong bro are you one of your
own fans you can't oh I get it he forgot
to switch from his sock puppet account
and he accidentally posted it from we
are change how embarrassing all right
ADP says the problem Black Rock State
Street Vanguard own everything they want
ESG perversion Fox loses 50 of its
viewers but gains 50 more adverts from
Nike J J Unilever Etc how do you
overcome that he's got to keep doing
what you're doing because those adverts
don't mean anything if nobody's buying
those products the circulation won't be
there so just gotta keep on keeping on
keep it up
what do we got Renault uh renovation
says sounds like Tucker might house
debates might be wrong but think on it
maybe
who knows what it'll do
if they have debates
they gotta have them yeah they gotta get
Trump to agree
Tuesday's Child says for Steve krakauer
do you think Megan would moderate a
debate on her show
for sure we'd love to yeah I mean like I
think Megan's moderated debates before
and uh she's notably with your trumpet
right when he called Roger O'Donnell fat
pig yes yes and then and then after that
you know had a grudge against Megan for
for months after that and caused a whole
bunch of stuff so uh yes no she's uh
she's fantastic she's great though she's
a fantastic debate moderator and uh
she'd love to do it again I'm sure we'll
love to do that right on let's grab some
more
did I read this one uh essay federalis
has working class Drinker here speaking
for us I loved a bush latte a bush light
until this bee came out saying Miller
High Life is the champagne of beers now
that was a period there and I didn't say
the entirety of the Super Chat
all right what do we got
track media only says one of the
greatest things the left has done up to
this point was convinced the right they
didn't boycott
is that what they're like convinced on
the right not to boycott well so what
happens every single time conservatives
say anything bothers them they go the
love goes I thought you were against
cancel culture as if being against
cancer culture means you're never upset
about anything that happens anywhere for
any reason and you'll buy any product
from anyone exactly so it's like a guy
who's you know literally in prison for
for killing someone and you're like he's
like there's no problem here exactly
I'll hire him to go to my preschool the
judge sentences him and the guy's like I
thought you were against cancer culture
bro but that's also the distinction like
I I there might be people who want Bud
Light to get shut down but I don't think
that's what a lot of the people who are
boycotting Bud Light feel I think
they're just saying I'm not buying that
I'm not going to support that and if we
get enough people to do that they're
going to lose money and they're you know
that's going to affect what they do I I
do think it may not actually be the
boycott I think the boycott may be much
smaller than we realize and what's
really driving this is that middle-aged
dudes don't want to look gay yeah and I
mean that
I mean in a literal sense like they they
associate Bud Light with lgbtq and they
don't want to be perceived that way in
this moment yeah so they're just like
I'm not I'm gonna buy that people are
going to think things about me you know
what I mean yeah if you don't like Bud
Light enough like if there's the
alternatives are okay enough for you
then you're gonna be fine to just find
an alternative in the short term Aaron
Cowell says check out Edgar watches
aside from good product they make
specific and directed anti-woke ads I
saw that that looks pretty cool Edgar
Edgard watches there's a viral video
they had an ad I guess it was like very
anti-woope
what do we got
Corey says Tim they recently adopted
saying they are for America America and
the Betsy Ross flag is no longer racist
who but but lighter what are you talking
about
no idea gravity says Fortunate Son is
badass that is correct Fortunate Son is
badass
Alexander scarpetti says Tucker
Carlson's ex producer sounds like
someone the Biden admin would hire
that's my question like what's the
vetting process at Fox News but this is
what people don't realize Fox News
employees are liberals yeah they live in
New York City yep they are not
conservatives yeah I I in the book I I
track you could spend about an hour and
a half and hit the headquarters of Fox
News which is across the street from the
headquarters of NBC CNN CBS New York
Times Wall Street Journal it's all in a
very like 20 block radius it's and and
Fox News you know they yes they cater to
a different audience but they're right
in that same area it's it's yeah it's
not as difference people think not
heisenberger says tell us about the
black sheep hat please
uh I got into buckle
I don't know I saw it online I thought
it was a cool hat there's no story
behind it I wish I had a cool story but
uh yeah I just love the hat
it's been through it's shiny
it is shiny I do like how shiny it is
Roger page says I have to strongly
disagree with Tim on kids not wanting to
be like others whoa whoa whoa I didn't
say that
you see what you did there
when kids play house they want to be
like their parents when kids play
pretend they want to be like someone
else maybe even a non-existent ideal I
never said we have to ask ourselves why
kids want to why kids want to be like
someone else I'm saying they why they so
desperately want to be someone other
than themselves
it is a fact that people want to be like
other people but they are themself
they're like I'm me this is what I look
like and if you want to be like someone
else you exercise you get fit you
practice you train and you make yourself
better I'm specifically talking about
people who don't even want to be in
their own bodies they want to be in
video games they want to be in avatars
or they want to be A different race or
gender or something not what they
literally are
but uh but I do agree with your
assessment I just think you
misinterpreted mine I think kids
absolutely imitate and want to be like
other people
still themselves though
okay let's grab some more Super chats
over here
what do we got
oh read that one
read that one read that one
um oh I went too far back
went too far back it jumps you know
because like super chips will all come
flying Bobcat says Tim I'm glad to see
you giving a job to a failed artist like
Sheamus have you thought about heading
up to the rod of iron Freedom Festival I
was really concerned when uh you know
Sheamus an art student and uh where he
might go if he didn't have proper
support and uh he may end up working for
the Democrats so yeah no that's exactly
it I was about to start comedy tunes and
that's right Tim came along and he said
you don't have to live that life I will
I will I will voice Dr fauci to save
your company that's what happened yep
the freedom Tunes is funded because Tim
pays me to voice Dr fauci that's where
we get all of them no no no no it was
failing until I voiced Dr fauci in a
masterpiece that's true of the Lord of
the Rings bet I won't deny it it's true
it's your best work the the Lord of the
Rings one it was an incredible video we
were we wrapped up a show and then I
can't remember exactly what it was we
were just riffing and saying stupid
things and you said I was there this
street the day the strength of trump
failed and I was pregnant we did this
whole improv today dude the original
improv we did was was way longer in the
video I mean it's been like 10 minutes
long because then like I came in I read
the script you read the script
explaining it as um
and then I was like Trump giving his
testimony and I was basically like
retelling The Lion King and like Trump
is Mufasa and fauci is scar
um and then we did a really offensive
one that you said you would never upload
oh my gosh we I feel like we did more
than one there's one we definitely did a
very offensive one we did one no yeah
yeah so fauci is in uh in Hollywood okay
and someone oh my gosh that's one there
we've done this yeah yeah there's
there's a few if you want to get a job
in this town yeah you gotta let me stick
it in there were there was a couple that
we never ran that one no I was like I'm
never I was like I'm not making that I
was like there's no way there's no way
save it I can't get enough vouch I mean
he is not going to go away and and the
The Tide is kind of turning on him now I
feel like with enough people that it's
only gonna get better I mean I want more
Dr fauci I do have to say the fauci one
I did uh blaming a bat that Tim also
reprized his vouchy voice in it was one
of our reasons everyone on the team I
said we were all very happy with that
one and how it turned out when the bat
goes
[Laughter]
yeah it was uh mocking making a making a
murderer or whatever it was just like
all of those crime shows you guys have
to check it out just go to Freedom tunes
and check out the the the uh lably
Cartoon we did with fauci it's blaming a
bat yeah oh man the factory one I really
do think Sheamus should have put it up
but Sheamus was like it's two it's too
grotesque that's right and it was like I
have standards yeah who are we worried
about offending fouchy or Harvey no I
just I usually just don't get like two
blue with the game I don't get sexual
yeah it was pretty awful yeah all right
where were we at
James Madison's go says did you hear
that trans Minnesota rep introduced bill
hf1655
to remove
all right we're gonna read it to remove
pitos as an exclusion to the protected
class of sexual orientation
we will uh we will go into detail on
that because it's a kind of a freaky
story and not very family friendly over
at timcast.com in the uncensored members
only show so that'll be on the front
page of timcast.com at about uh 10 10
p.m Eastern you want to be a member to
watch that and um we'll take some calls
from the audience but let's read some
more
Ted Thornton says indoctrinate your kids
with truths as soon as possible when
they are when they are a sponge the more
of us that do this the more likely it
spreads through friend groups to
encounter to public education kids
understand more than we think
I agree kids are smart it's always weird
that people people say like kids are so
dumb they're not they're actually really
smart they just lack information so the
difference between not being smart and
lacking information there's a lot of
people who are very very smart but lack
information and you'll be like I can't
believe you didn't know this but they're
really good at like math and solving
problems and things like that yeah their
brains aren't fully formed to the point
where they can really make logical
decisions or work their way through
things but they remember things in in
such an incredible manner
yeah they start going down that road of
logic though I have to say like the
things that seem illogical now in our
politics like I I have a six year old oh
yeah and it's like it's like you know
even if you start to scratch a surface
it's like wait why what do you and yeah
that's actually a good point yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Roberto Jr is
the second best Junior
um he's the first the best Junior
where are we at Jeremy wyan says someone
needs to make that picture a rooster
facing a predator we have a flag it's uh
it's like it's a stand your ground flag
and it's Roberto Jr rooster like
Standing Tall with his wings out the the
rooster has to be protecting kids from a
drag queen Story Hour the rooster's like
in between the kids
I kind of just like the idea that it's
protecting the chickens from a snake or
something he could just be I'll go he
could go around for he he has to protect
children because human men won't
yep he runs into danger that's what he
does
uh Kamala Nora says women want real men
I only see real men on your show Tucker
will do fine a b is done because real
men say say so
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Scott Dietrich says Busch Gardens is not
associated with Anheuser-Busch as of a
few years ago they are separate
companies
hmm well there you go
what do we have the bell bell says the
Brent Mason Telly is the Tucker Carlson
of Tim cast to bring it back it's this
right there it's like it's over that
side and then I have the harmony
silhouette behind me everybody likes the
Brent Mason I guess I like the colors
but I play the silhouette more so
it's a good guitar
where are we at
Roger page says that was a good response
thank you Tim well thank you for your
Super Chat
what is this Michael TB says amusement
parks only thing wholly owned by
Anheuser-Busch so Busch Gardens is
different I guess
Mac rabbit says in the Hispanic culture
they call the dad new fathers El Gallo
pronounced guyo rooster that's right El
Gallo means the rooster buck
Derek Manson says potato Boy versus
funky last name t-shirt guy Feud of the
century that's right I can accept those
names we have the last name T-shirt boy
he's so jealous he's so jealous we got a
Polish a Polish Rooster
mail order in an AG and then you
incubate him and when he hatched he's uh
it's yeah it's polisher okay so he has a
cool haircut where his hair comes on it
Parts down the middle and he's blonde
and he's got a big nose and Luke was
here and he was like he's like hey he
looks he looks like you know he looks
just like me he's got a big he's
polishing he's got a big nose and we're
so we named him little Luke okay and now
I tell people not only does he have the
parted hair and a big nose but he
screams a lot yeah yeah exactly does he
stick up for the chickens does he uh
protect them he actually he actually is
separated because the the Polish
chickens and roosters have domed heads
so you don't want to mix them because if
they Peck each other they'll die oh well
it'll give him a concussion and then oh
yeah and then they eat the body because
chickens are brutal they're brutal
animals honestly yeah
Raymond g Stanley Jude says Tim haramf I
say it's a poem not a rap amigo oh well
there you go you know I read your poem
you read your poem vanity says started a
YouTube channel talking politics from
Blue Collar when I get the play button
will you do a kick flip on it Tim first
superchat by the way you're gonna send
me your your your uh button you want me
to kickflip on you know what we could do
is we could I have I have a bunch of
those golden play awards from YouTube I
think we have like five and uh we use
one of them as a to prop the window open
we just like stick it in the window and
it's you know but we could we could
mount it to some some trucks and
skateboard on it that'd be funny do you
get that at a million yeah okay yeah
we're nearing that at the Megyn Kelly
show I have to say we got like one on
the floor that's the one we used to prop
up the wind pop up in the window yeah
because it's just it is kind of funny
I'm sure there are people out there that
are like I wish I had one of those and
it's like yeah but a million used to be
something bigger than it is now because
there was a period where it was really
really hard now there's like a million
channels in the millions like
everybody's got one you know and then
people buy fake ones or whatever you
know what calm down Tim okay a million's
an accomplishment well yeah no for sure
I mean we have a bunch of them I'm Tim
I'm too cool to
this is heavy the rumble the rumble
award but I just gotta say to the rumble
guys it says Tim cast IRL 500 000
followers we we don't have 500 000
followers on Rumble wow hold on let me
see what you have on Rumble right it's
like 375 or 400 or something you don't
deserve a one of them in advance but the
actual account has like a million or
something you have 387 000 yeah yeah and
then the the multiple channels on it add
up to like 800 or 900 000 or something
like that I think that's why they sent
it but they just put instead of putting
Tim I think Tim guy style might be the
account name so if you look at the
channel it just says 300 or whatever but
but I guess on Rumble One account has
multiple channels and the followers
count towards the one count or something
but this is cool this is super heavy
that's like you could hurt somebody with
this thing
anyway we're almost thrown them that was
awesome you know Crowder Russell Brand
it's kind of oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and but more importantly is the
skateboarding stuff they're doing in
video games they're they're getting
outside of politics yeah all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member we're gonna have a very unfamily
friendly uncensored show coming up for
you at about 10 10 P.M so uh you're
gonna You're Not Gonna Wanna Miss this
one unless you don't like hearing about
weird gross things and law and uh but
this one's a serious uh serious uh show
if you become a member at least 25 per
month or if you're a member for at least
six months you can actually call into
the show so sign up we'd love to see you
in the Discord you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Steve you want to
shout anything out yeah so uncovered is
my book read uncover.com readuncover.com
to find it it doesn't just look at what
happened the last seven years but why it
happened how it happened be prepared for
when it happens again and kind of give
you the tools to do that right on my
name is Seamus Coughlin I make cartoons
at a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes if you guys want to go over there
check them out we're releasing cartoon
tomorrow on the whole Tucker Carlson
debacle I also have a podcast and live
stream at the chain uh the channel
shamer on Rumble so that's rumble.com
shamer if y'all want to go check that
out
word Adrian Norman staff writer here Tim
Cass uh you can find me here on social
media I'm at Adrian Norman DC on Rumble
it's actually just Adrian Norman as well
as truth social and YouTube
and I am search.com it's a good show
tonight thanks guys we will see you all
over at timcast.com in about 10 minutes
don't miss it we'll see y'all there